ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen it is here it is her son
magnavitation deceased is back and son
son son Tom Taylor starts us off with a
bang okay here's the thing here's the
thing right DC's is finally back
Superman Returns in this story thank God
right so we get to see whatever came of
like zombies Superman was gonna be
awesome not a spoiler because a ton of
other stuff happens here but here's the
kicker as you guys know deceased is a
monthly release which means we cover
this one today we don't cover the next
one until like September like late
September September 20th and then we
gotta wait to the end of October and so
on and so forth let it comes out once a
month I still say they should have
released these as an original graphic
novel having said that this story is
amazing right so what this does and it's
actually one of the coolest things what
this does is it opens up on Krypton with
the city of Candor and the origin of
Supergirl remember Supergirl is a
character that we haven't seen yet in
DC's like we have not seen her yet and
it's one of the cool things because the
more I read DC's the more I think it
kind of feels like Injustice in terms of
all of Tom Taylor's World building and
so what we end up getting here is
Supergirl basically being sent away from
Krypton by her family and instead of
arriving on Earth she travels somewhere
else now all of this is really being
given to us by way of like literally
Brainiac showing up here krypton's and
imminent end it's destruction all that
kind of stuff what you normally expect
from the origin of Supergirl but here's
the cool thing right here's the funny
thing that happens so the statement
that's made by her by her family by her
parents is this it will take many years
for you to reach your new home daughter
though Krypton will be long gone to you
it will seem like no time has passed we
have searched throughout the Universe
and we have found a planet When You
Reach This World you will have
incredible abilities but you will not be
alone in this there will be others on
this world with fantastic Powers you
will be special but not apart and when
she arrives here this statement her
parents make is we are sending you to
new genesis jorel would send his son to
live with Primitives we we are sending
you to live with Gods the crazy thing
about this is when she arrives on new
genesis everybody's infected with the
anti-life virus remember like literally
Dark Side went nuts he was the first to
truly be infected outside of like cyborg
but he was the first the first being to
truly be infected and then seemingly
went on a Warpath new genesis was hit by
that which means High father and all
these new gods that exist out there in
DC Comics they're all zombified if we
want to use that phrase right but
they're all basically they're infected
with the anti-life virus enough for
those of you guys coming from Marvel
Comics and you're not necessarily sure
what all this means imagine that like a
being like Galactus was infected with
the anti-life virus and it was like a
planet of galactuses and that's what
you're looking at right that's the kind
of thing you're looking at like the kind
of mid-level cosmic entity so let's say
somebody like Mephisto and Thanos and
Galactus and these guys that's the level
of power that we're talking about here
it's pretty intense now I use those
comparisons as more of like a contextual
thing so before some of you guys get in
the comments and you're like Nerf derp
derp actually Thanos is not as powerful
as high father Derpy derp I'm not making
a power comparison I'm simply just
saying that like these guys are at least
in terms of the role they play they're
comparable but the thing about this is
where Supergirl initially flees for her
life one thing to remember is that the
new gods are in a lot of ways on her
same level of power and so she is
seemingly immediately overtaken by these
guys and then infected by the virus so
quite literally she arrives on this
world and then basically dies and so
following that what you end up doing is
of course you kind of get a little bit
of an explanation from Tom Taylor
insofar as where things stand which is
to say that yes there was the anti-life
virus that broke out on Earth but they
ultimately discovered a cure so while
not every single person across the world
is cured most are and they're still
curing a ton every day but lest we
forget there is basically the
superheroes who exist here on Earth but
one of the things you remember is at the
end of the first DC's comic a bunch of
the heroes escaped Earth they took off
right they literally got in spaceships
and left they're gone so there are some
superheroes who are still here but a lot
of the ones that we know have basically
taken off and so what we end up doing
here is of course switching over to the
ones who are here right so you have
Damien Wayne who's the new Batman you
have Jonathan Kent who's the new
Superman so on and so forth and what
they're trying to figure out is what
they're going to do initially Jonathan's
like now that we have a cure it's time
to go find my dad it's time to go find
Superman and to basically save him you
know the other part of this is Damian
just being like I could come with you
right like I could I could join you on
this and it's kind of a funny banter
back and forth because Jonathan's whole
thing is like I mean it's the center of
the sun Damian I doubt Batman has the
the ability or any technology I doubt
that Bruce had any anything that would
allow him to enter the center of the sun
now as we know from Batman comics the
fact that Batman is literally this guy
can just reach into his pocket and have
whatever he needs at any point in time
in order to defeat somebody because prep
time or something like that he probably
did uh but it's still a funny thing
what's really cool about this though
that's one of the things that I love
about Tom Taylor Tom Taylor's great when
it comes to developing interpersonal
relationships and what is in effect a
post-apocalyptic story right like
Injustice kind of felt post-apocalyptic
to it three and so far as the heroes as
we knew them versus the heroes as they
exist now and then of course like DC's
is absolutely a post-apocalyptic story
where Society is kind of rebuilding
itself but the relationship between
Jonathan and Damian has largely been
maintained these guys know each other
just as well as they ever did and
they've become some of the best of
friends that you could possibly imagine
so it's no wonder why it is that
Jonathan is not in any rush to let
Damian join him in the center of the Sun
not necessarily even knowing if Damien
can survive but at the end of the day
the decision is made right because of
the fact that this is essentially
Superman and because this is Superman
who spent the last five years at the
center of the sun remember when the
whole DC's thing first ended up
happening when it first popped off
towards the end of the story Superman
was infected he ended up being infected
by the anti-life virus and when the
heroes were trying to escape those who
managed to get away from Earth when they
were trying to take off they were
initially being attacked ultimately
Superman was momentarily held off and
then ended up basically walking away
right ended up flying into the sun to
basically charge himself with solar
energy and has been doing so for the
last five years and that's what's kind
of crazy is because when the heaviest
hitters who were here on Earth get to
the Sun and they get to where Superman
is one of course they have the Cure but
two they didn't realize how radically
things had changed that when Jonathan is
told by Green Canary right when
basically Dinah Dinah Lance Black Canary
following the death of uh of Hal Jordan
she basically ended up becoming the new
Green Lantern that when this happened
that she tells him that's not your
father in there Jonathan that's
something that you have to keep in mind
that's not your dad that is an infected
guy so while the goal is to cure him if
it comes down to the fact that we can't
we may have to kill him and that has to
be something that you can be okay with
and while Jonathan doesn't necessarily
say that he is at the end of the day he
has to be there's no alternative here
either Superman gets cured or Superman
has to die and so entering into the Sun
what Jonathan and really the others
failed to take into account or maybe
just hadn't really been able to
understand the full gravity of is how
powerful Superman would become sitting
in the core of the Sun for five straight
years absorbing all of its solar energy
like just standing there absorbing solar
energy right I mean Superman is powered
by solar energy so he's faster and
stronger than anybody could have ever
imagined and faster and stronger than
he's ever been in his existence a
perfect example of this is that green
Canary literally creates a hard-like
construct to encase Superman and Tom
Taylor kind of plays with this idea and
saying that under any normal
circumstance this would have held him
under any normal circumstance Superman
would have been encased and he would
have been able to get away he would he
shattered it in an instant right just
like literally just broke it like glass
now with enough time normal Superman
probably would have been able to escape
but that's one of the things to know
about Tom Taylor's writing his depiction
of characters from one story to the next
outside of DC's continuity really
changes so Superman during Injustice For
example was stupidly overpowered I mean
it was nuts how powerful he was and some
would actually argue it was the most
accurate depiction of Superman's
strength that's been done in DC Comics
for for quite some time which if I'm
being honest I'm kind of inclined to
agree with others would say he was just
wildly overpowered for the sake of the
story so that's why Tom Taylor's writing
when it comes to characters you can't
necessarily take their strength levels
as he depicts them as an absolute truth
it's just one of many variations that's
why we kind of have a main DC Universe
and just a bass line that exists out
there but the thing about this is that
it literally takes all these guys to try
to step in and do something and they're
literally trying to hold Superman off as
best they can but we never actually find
out or at least we don't find out here
what happens all we know is they
seemingly haven't held in place and then
basically like green green Canary is
like now right like cyborg inject him
and so what you end up doing is jumping
to Earth two two days later and this is
cool because what it basically says is
like this is where the other Heroes had
gone off to right they had basically
formed kind of a new world for
themselves A New Earth and that's one of
the things to know that it happened
right at the end of the uh the the main
BC series that the heroes found a new
place to live when they arrive here of
course you've got president Lane right
Lois Lane who's basically acting
president you've got Guy Gardner you've
got uh Jon Stewart The Green Lanterns
that we're usually familiar with but
while they're here suddenly they're met
by the arrival or at least the energy
signature of an apocalyptian Force which
of course turns out to be a boom tube
but as soon as this opens their first
thought is like we're under attack right
like everybody responds but the thing
about this is that once the tube opens
it's actually the good guys not only is
it the good guys it's this really
beautiful and amazing moment because you
basically get like Superman who shows up
who's been essentially cured right not
only that when his arm was ripped off
before it's been replaced by a new arm
which is really really awesome so of
course Lois Lane is very excited to see
her man but in the other part of this
and this is probably one of the More
Beautiful Moments here is that Jonathan
Kent was also cured like the actual
Jonathan Kent right like Superman's dad
so now you have like you have like the
entire family essentially reunited right
Jonathan and Martha are reunited the
Superman and Lois are reunited it's a
very beautiful moment here not only that
where you do have uh yeah big Barta and
you've got Scott free of course they're
cured again and their intention is to go
back to go back home to basically new
genesis or at least to apocalypse or
what have you and to find their son
wherever it is that he may be because
one of the things you remember is that
that entire area is in a complete and
total state of chaos and because it's in
a state of chaos they don't know exactly
where their son is all they can do is
just go to that realm and hope that they
can somehow find him now they don't know
that everything's bad but the crazy
thing here and what's really also a bit
of Torment is you switch over to Damien
talking to Alfred and actually revealing
everything to Alfred insofar as they
have a cure and all that kind of stuff
now the thing about this is Alfred would
have found out eventually and so it was
really the the responsibility of Damien
to say to Alfred there is a cure for the
anti-life virus we can bring everybody
back the bigger reason why Alfred is so
tortured by this is because if you
remember in the original DC's event when
Batman when Bruce Wayne was infected
nobody knew what it was and Alfred had
to kill Bruce Wayne and he had to kill
Tim Drake and Dick Grayson he literally
killed them all with a shotgun so
they're dead they're not infected just
kind of roaming around out there they
had to die and that's the thing Alfred
takes it as a massive personal loss and
the truth from what Damien says is you
would have found out about this and so
it was my responsibility to tell you but
there's no way you could have known what
would have happened there's no way you
could have known that there would have
been a cure developed for this all we
knew is that all these different
superhero these beings out there were
infected by some kind of zombified virus
and they would have killed everybody
they could find or infect everybody they
could find you did what you thought was
the right thing at that point in time
but Alfred still rejects that and says
like no I killed my sons right and so
it's one of those things where as a
father figure he just can't let that go
he just can't walk away from this and so
what you do is you switch over to what
isn't a fact about the next day and you
have all these Brainiac probes that end
up arriving and basically showing up to
Earth too now initially they're taken
out by like Superman and Jessica Cruz
one of the other Green Lanterns and so
on and so forth right the Green Lantern
Court self spawns as you would expect
and so these probes are kind of
annihilated because their first thought
is okay one these probes are a credible
threat because each one of these guys
are very capable but two Brainiac probes
mean brainiac's arrival is imminent and
he literally shows up hours later now
here's the crazy thing once they get to
The Brainiac vessel they start to
realize that like something's wrong the
ships in ragtag condition it looks like
it's basically limping Along by all
standards of measurement this Brainiac
ship looks like a car that's falling
apart and is out of gas and is literally
just kind of limping along the highway
the into it just stops that's basically
what this looks like it's just in a
dilapidated condition and Brainiac is
nothing if not meticulous and so this
idea of his ship just being torn asunder
and in little bits and pieces it's
concern for everybody because the
thought of of Superman or at least the
thought of Jon Stewart is Superman can
you see inside right can you use your
X-ray vision to see and his response is
no that was one of the first things
Brainiac did when he developed a shift
was to design it in such a way to where
I can't see inside anybody with x-ray
vision can't see inside to minimize any
weaknesses that this vessel may have so
the only alternative they have is to go
in right literally Guy Gardner is like
we have to go in there like we've got to
get inside this ship and we have to see
what's going on which means we may find
ourselves in a face-to-face
confrontation with Brainiac now where
Superman tells Jonathan I'm going in you
have to wait here this is Superman not
necessarily realizing how far his son
has come Jonathan has been through a lot
and he's experienced a lot and grown up
much faster than Superman possibly could
have imagined of course because surround
was a zombified he was in the sun no way
he could have known but this is not one
of those instances when Jonathan stays
behind and he even says that I'm not
staying here and so at the end of the
day it's Jonathan and Superman who enter
into the ship and when they get in there
what they find is that Brainiac is no
longer a threat instead like his body's
been ripped in half he's just kind of
hanging there just sort of strung up and
he's like we have to stop him the gods
are dead but they still come Kalel they
will poison the universe and the gods
will end everything all right what's
going on guys this is Rob and we are
back with DC's dwar of the undead Gods
part two the second part of the final
chapter of the DC story as always if you
guys are new to the channel make sure
you guys check out the playlist down in
the description so you can get caught up
so here's the thing in the last video we
basically talked about how in effect the
anti-life virus which is sort of a
stand-in for a zombie virus to a degree
that it had basically been cured right
and the efforts of the superheroes or at
least what's left of the superheroes was
to travel across the universe and cure
pretty much any of the places that have
been infected but they don't know that
like Darkseid is back right he's still
infected with the anti-life virus and so
on and so forth so one of the things
that happens right this initially
focuses on scot-free and big Barta right
Mr Miracle now for those of you guys who
don't know these guys are what are
called New Gods so the reality here is
that these folks are wildly powerful
something to know about when it comes to
New Gods is they are all on in some way
equivalent to like Superman Wonder Woman
those guys in term terms of power
they're all hugely powerful right
they're not exactly equal and it kind of
varies depending on one person to the
next but like scot-free for example can
break out of any prison no matter what
it is anywhere in the universe and big
Barda while she's just big and she's
badass right that's basically what that
is but the idea behind this is that they
had a son and when the initial virus
went off their son was basically taken
to new genesis which is the home of the
New Gods in order to basically keep him
safe right what better place to keep him
away from the entire apocalypse than a
place that can only be accessed by those
with Godly powers and a place that is a
home to Godly beings that are easily
able to overcome virtually any Force
within the realm of DC Comics and so as
a result of that once they end up
getting back there one of the things
that we saw in the last video right at
the end of the last video was the story
of Supergirl who was just now being
introduced to the story remember like
the whole idea of DC's takes place in an
alternate reality and so what we found
out with Supergirl is unlike the main DC
Universe where her origin sees her
arriving on Earth instead she arrived on
new genesis not only that apocalypse had
attacked new genesis and basically
turned virtually everybody there into
one of his anti-life forces right kind
of like a zombie so to speak and so as
soon as Supergirl arrived she was
immediately attacked and converted and
so once scot-free and big Barta arrive
here not realizing what's going on they
immediately find that new genesis has
fallen right the new gods have basically
Fallen they don't really know exactly
what's going on they just know that
things are really bad but their
immediate concern is to look for their
son and then noticing a dark portal off
to the side big Barta initially goes to
enter and is stopped by the black racer
now for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with the black racer in DC
Comics is one of the many allegories of
death in DC that the black racer is just
kind of this personification of the Grim
Reaper to a degree he's really the most
popular version of the Grim Reaper but
different personifications or aspects of
death exist out there but by and large
whenever the black racer appears it is a
being that simply cannot be outran with
the exception of like Barry Allen The
Flash and like that's it and the result
to this is that when it comes to the
black racer showing up here it actually
rescues big Barta now the reason why
this matters is because the black racer
despite the fact that it is the Grim
Reaper it can be killed if you are
powerful enough you can destroy the
black racer the reason why this matters
is because with the fall of new genesis
the black racer is just one of the
survivors and literally it tells them
dark side is back dark side is the
unliving god Darkseid is the one who is
controlling the entirety of all these
forces with the anti-life virus he
attacked new genesis he's bolstering his
army and it's going to spread across the
entirety of the universe unless we can
find some way to stop it and so the
first thing that Darkseid does right
after destroying new genesis and taking
it over bolstering his army with the
power of the new Gods the first main
world that exists out there in the
universe that doesn't belong to any of
the Gods the first one they attack is
karuger now for those of you guys who
are familiar with DC Comics bear with me
here for a second for those of you guys
who aren't karuga is the home planet of
Thal sinestra so thalcinestro is
arguably one of the most powerful Green
Lanterns to have ever existed he
ultimately ended up becoming kind of a
dictator of his own Homeworld instead of
protecting karuger and that sector he
actually just kind of became this ruler
that that literally controlled it with
an Iron Fist and because he betrayed the
charter of the Green Lanterns he was
ultimately exiled from the Green Lantern
Corps and then formed his own core
called the Sinestro core in that where
the Green Lantern Corps feeds on
Willpower right how much gumption how
much strength you have to overcome the
odds that the Sinestro core is empowered
by fear how scared are you and the
result of this is that Peru or Falls
instantly I mean these guys never had a
chance like it's not even senestro or
those guys who are here it's basically
just the planetary defense of karuger
but these guys don't stand a chance
against the power of of New Gods it's
like an army of Superman just descending
on this world there's nothing they can
do they never had a chance to begin with
but fortunately for them an SOS gets
shot out into space and Thal Sinestro
overhears it right now he's currently
the ruler of war world and the main DC
Universe uh war world is actually ruled
by somebody else that basically turns
into like a giant tournament World a
giant battle world where all people do
is just fight to the death but without
Sinestro ruling it this is where his
Sinestro core resides so we can largely
assume the reason behind the celestial
core's existence is the same here in
DC's as it is in the main DC Universe
but the the reality here and really what
he basically declares is like we are
gonna go save my homework Ruger now
under any normal Circumstance the
celestial core would never do this and
if they did they would arrive there to
feed on the fear of that world in order
to bolster their own power and that
would largely be it right these are this
is not a humanitarian peacekeeping Force
they don't do things because it's the
right thing to do that's the Green
Lantern Corps right the Sinestro core
just exists to bolster its own power and
so what we end up doing is that while
they respond we switch over to Superman
and we switch over to basically some of
the superheroes on Earth because
remember Brainiac had come along now
Brainiac is wildly powerful brainiac's
hugely capable and Brainiac fell before
the power of Darkseid and this is really
just DC showing us how far gone Darkseid
is and the level of power that Darkseid
possesses because the on running theme
Here is that with Darkseid being
possessed by the anti-life virus then in
a lot of ways darkseid's not even in
control of his own faculties he's more
part of a hive mind if you want to call
it that than anything else but he's just
kind of the leader so to speak right
he's kind of the the one that sort of
Marshals everything and leads everything
and so it's a cool scenario because in
this case you have literally the
superheroes who are here outside of
Superman who were like why would we
trust Brainiac this guy's a bad guy this
guy literally travels Across the
Universe he basically captures entire
cities and then shrinks them down for
his own personal collection countless
beings have died because of the actions
of Brainiac why would we trust him and
the reality here is the enemy of my
enemy is my friend that's literally what
it boils down to that that dark side is
the main focus here right dark side is
the main bad guy here and in times of
desperation this is what it leads to
that what you have are the forces of
Darkseid spreading across the universe
like a plague and it cannot be easily
stopped that even somebody like Brainiac
as powerful as he is fell before the
power of Darkseid something to keep in
mind Brainiac is a challenge for
Superman on a good day this is the this
is the kind of being that we're looking
at here falling before a dark side in
that capacity shows us just how dire
things really are and so the result of
this is okay like this is the alliance
that we're making we're allying
ourselves with Brainiac and not only
that we're reaching out to every single
being across the universe that has not
Fallen before the power of Darkseid and
they're gonna we're all gonna become
allies even if they've just been mortal
enemies over the years even if all
they've ever tried to do is destroy us
at the end of the day saving the
universe is more important than these
stupid Petty squabbles that we have with
these various villains that exist out
there because the unifying factor that
we all share is we want to live and
that's a very powerful motivator and so
what this does is it switches back
directly over to thousinestro and this
is a really really cool moment because
Val Sinestro literally taking the power
of war world that his intention is not
to destroy the entirety of Kruger but
instead to basically start firing on
those who are possessed by the anti-life
and Destroy them the problem here is the
attack is stopped by the arrival of
sironic Natsu and Kyle Raynor now Kyle
Raynor being here is one of the cooler
things right in DC Comics Hal Jordan was
like the most popular Green Lantern for
years and years and years and then
eventually DC killed him off and they
replaced him with Kyle Rayner who
arguably was equally if not more popular
but he was the main Green Lantern for
about a decade all throughout pretty
much the mid to late 1990s and the early
2000s until Hal Jordan was eventually
brought back as the Green Lantern by
Jeff Johnson is the daughter of
thousinestro now in the main DC Universe
like Kyle Rainer andronic not to kind of
had it on again off-again relationship
until the Robert venditti run of Green
Lantern when they basically became
enemies
and there was no love lost there right
she hated Kyle Raynor because Kyle
Raynor basically ended up having to
destroy their future son and because
that was the case things just kind of
parted ways here in this universe
they're married which is really cool to
actually see that their relationship
worked out but they don't understand the
full totality of the situation as far as
they're concerned thou Sinestro is up to
his old tricks and attacking karuga
again now the funny thing about this is
thousandestro himself being so arrogant
and so full of hubris doesn't bother to
explain what it is that he's actually
doing it's just one of those things
where he's like I know better than you
two stay out of my way right I have a
bigger Mission here the problem is that
their conversation is immediately
interrupted by the arrival of Supergirl
and the reality here is remember the
anti-life virus operates with what's
basically a hive mind and seeing that
thou Sinestro had War World at his
disposal that war world is powerful
enough to destroy the entirety of karuga
if it needs to and certainly obliterate
most of those new Gods who exist on
kuruga itself and are in the process of
conquering it and so because the mother
boxes serve as much of a transportation
device as they do the ability to
transfer the virus to somebody else
Supergirl literally takes a mother box
and smashes it into war world and
because it is a technological Planet
it's overtaken by the anti-life virus
what this does is it literally turns War
World from just this controllable object
into one that works on behalf of the
anti-life virus and can now literally go
through the universe and just start
spewing the anti-life virus onto
everybody or just annihilating entire
worlds right imagine those of you guys
coming from Marvel Comics imagine that
Galactus was infected with this
anti-life virus and that's more or less
what you're looking at here in terms of
Destruction on a planetary level and the
ability to spread that destruction over
a rapid amount of time and so with Kyle
weiner being knocked out with archilo
who is really one of the more popular
members of the Sinestro core being
destroyed it really just comes down to
thousinestro and sironic Natsu the
problem with this is Darkseid makes his
move and Darkseid emerges onto the scene
now initially in the way that we're told
is like you have Sinestro and you have
his daughter basically a Yellow Lantern
and a Green Lantern fighting side by
side and there is equilibrium and in
fact they're an even mat for the power
of of Darkseid and his Omega beams and
they're actually holding him off the
problem is what little equilibrium
existed here is immediately nullified
when Supergirl goes back on the offense
and literally gives the upper hand to
Darkseid and when that happens Darkseid
immediately sees his thousinestro and in
these dying moments and probably what's
just one of the greatest moments of
thousand nestro God it's for now dude
the way this ends is amazing so in one
of these like like these these kind of
dying moments of Sinestro he literally
tells saronic you have to run right you
have to get out of here you have to live
so that you can free karuger you have to
find allies people who can fight on our
side and people who can ensure the
survival of the universe only you can
protect this world and in that moment as
soon as done saying that Darkseid kills
Sinestro by ripping his head off and
literally all that can happen here Kyle
Wainer is just like we have to go we
can't stay here if we stay we die like
this guy killed Sinestro Sinestro is
more powerful than we are there's no way
we can overcome this force and so with
Kyle Rayner and sironic not to doing the
only thing they can do which is to just
Flee for their lives and then try to
find some measure of allies that exists
out there most likely Superman and the
the existing Justice League that what
this does is it switches back to dark
side and with thousand nestro having
died as you guys know when a lantern
dies as long as the ring is not
destroyed it searches for a new
replacement and that's exactly what the
ring does right ring status report
Sinestro 1 deceased scan for replacement
sentient initiated scan for replacement
and then it immediately goes to dark
side and it's like you have the ability
to instill great fear welcome to the
Sinestro core and dark side officially
becomes a Yellow Lantern so this story
is gonna have one of the most amazing
endings ever so make sure you guys stick
around for that but uh I kind of forgot
that DC was doing deceased
not gonna lie I'm a little bit ashamed
uh I gotta get caught up you know what I
mean so here's the thing uh picking back
up with this right we come off issues
one and two make sure you guys check the
playlist down in the description so you
can get caught up we're literally two
issues in so we're just kind of picking
up with issues three and four in this
video so you don't have a whole lot of
catching up to do but what this does is
this initially focuses on a guy by the
name of Adam Strange now Adam Strange is
a cool character and he's a guy that you
don't really see a whole lot of Stories
being done with but he's got one of the
most interesting aspects to any
character in DC Comics so check this out
the idea behind Adam Strange and he's an
old Julia Schwartz character from back
in the 1950s the idea behind Adam
Strange is that on the planet ran right
you basically had the Emperor who did
what's the equivalent of like shining a
flashlight from half a mile away in the
middle of the desert right like you'd
see that light and just be like what's
that right and you would go and see what
it was so the idea behind the people of
ran is they literally sent a Zeta beam
down to earth and the hopes that like
people on Earth would be like what in
the world is this they would trace it
back to its source and they would come
into contact with an extraterrestrial
race right expand the possibilities of
humanity what ended up happening is the
Zeta beam was mutated through Cosmic
radiation so when it hit Adam Strange it
basically gave him powers and then it
teleported him to the planet of ran
where he basically ended up falling in
love with his chick named Alana right
he's actually got a child right so they
they basically have a kid together but
the idea behind this data beam is that
there is no real controlling it right
like Adam Strange will be teleported to
ran and then he'll be there for a little
while then the Zeta beam will randomly
teleport him back there's no way of
knowing when that's going to happen so
the idea behind his character is that he
would literally just run around Earth
trying to find where the new Zeta beam
was going to arrive and then ride the
beam back to Rand where he would offer a
really kind of operate as a protector of
the planet while also trying to be with
his love interest it was cool right it
was really really cool DC never really
knew what to do with him but the story
behind him was great and that's
literally what happens here right ran is
one of the worlds that is under attack
at the hands of basically the undead
Armada right if you guys remember
everything we covered in the first two
issues of War of the undead gods that
dark side has now re-emerged infected
with the anti-life equation right
basically this kind of anti-life version
of like a zombie virus not only that
darkseid's also a Yellow Lantern now
right so it's a immensely powerful dark
side more so than he normally is and
this literally allowed all these zombies
that have basically been moving around
the universe and infecting worlds to
coalesce under the power of Darkseid and
then start moving forward with an
intention right to literally start
conquering world after world after world
and so where Adam Strange is teleported
away his wife and his kid are basically
left there to fend for themselves as
best they can along with whatever
survivors are there now it's not
something that takes them by surprise
again Alana is well familiar with this
his kids well familiar with this right
they're aware it's just how these things
go and iron chronically enough one of
the downside of his character is that
these things The Zeta beam would always
activate at the most inconvenient time
right so literally this is the worst
time for the beam to activate but when
it does it teleports him back down to
earth and he arrives in Gotham City two
months before a cure is found for the
anti-life virus and so what ends up
happening is that as he's making his way
through Gotham he sees Wonder Woman
while he's trying to understand what had
happened here once he sees Wonder Woman
of course she was infected this is of
course before she died but she was
infected she immediately attacks Adam
Strange and turns Adam Strange into one
of the zombies so what ends up happening
is about two weeks later Adam Strange is
teleported back to Rand using a Zeta
beam and when he arrives he's infected
and then attacks his family so it's just
the craziest thing right it's absolutely
Bonkers now a few days after that we
basically transition over to the rilex
system with one of the coolest moments
right one of the absolute best moments
in this it's not the crazy ending I was
telling you about but it is one of the
coolest moments right so basically here
in this bar and when you guys you guys
know when we're talking about a bar out
in space in DC Comics you know who we're
talking about we're talking about the
main man Lobo himself that's right
ladies and gentlemen now anybody out
there who's not familiar with Lobo this
guy was designed back in the day to be
like an over-the-top version of
Wolverine from Marvel Comics that
basically was on par with the power of
Superman Lobo is a host right this guy
is amazing but the thing about this is
this guy kind of shows up out of nowhere
and says like I'm looking for somebody
Noble who can basically you know help
thin the universe against whatever
threat is out there right this massive
threat that's kind of running around
we're looking for somebody to help us uh
is anybody down right is anybody you
know interested in this now of course
lobo's like what does it pay and this
guy is like I am looking for someone
Noble you clearly do not fit that
description now the problem here is
everybody hears this said and it's just
kind of like bruh
that ain't what you want to say to a man
like Lobo
right but the crazy thing about this is
before Lobo can help this guy finish
with all his living we end up having a
thanagerian warship that arrives onto
the scene and as this warship emerges of
course all these thanagarians who had
basically been taken over by the
anti-life virus basically the race where
like Hawkman and hot girl come from that
they literally start like pouring into
the entirety of the bar and even the
planet as a whole and start attacking
everybody now the funny thing about this
is one of these guys attacks Lobo and
they scratch it now under normal
circumstances a person would change Lobo
does not because Lobo has an insane
healing Factor he can heal from pretty
much anything in fact the Lobo has been
cut into pieces and then just
reconstituted himself again his his
level of just strength and durability
and healing factor is designed to be
ridiculously over the top in comical in
this story it pays off because this
guy's like this guy's like you do not
turn and lobo's like oh I can turn right
I can keep turning and turning until
your head comes off your shoulders and
like rips his head off
and he's like nobody starts killing
Lobos bartenders without Lobo doing
anything about it so Lobo literally
shows up here and annihilates the
entirety of not only the thanagarian
warship but most of the thanagarians
themselves and that's where this guy is
like okay so like I guess you are the
warrior I was looking for right a guy
who's really capable I mean he got
problems right but we could use you
right I mean you know it's it's we can
make it work you know what I mean we can
make it work right so literally what we
do here is we switch over to the mascara
now again the mascara is throwing a
funeral for Wonder Woman now it's one of
those things that's really cool here
because of course Diana was turned by
the virus and then literally was
instrumental in slaughtering I don't
know how many people on Earth but the
thing about this is before all of that
she was Diana right like the princess of
the mascara Wonder Woman and Amazon so
it's one of those things where just
because she was turned by a virus and
led to the wholesale Slaughter of pretty
much all with Humanity doesn't make her
a bad guy right we all make mistakes
right we all make mistakes we all do
things that we don't mean to do and
sometimes we say things we don't mean to
say but in all seriousness right Wonder
Woman has always been an exceedingly
honorable member of the superhero
community and because of that her people
on the mascara she's a sister to them so
it's less that Wonder Woman went on this
Rampage is some kind of a villain and
more that she was a victim of a
circumstance that she couldn't control
and so with this this funeral being uh
held for her what you end up having is
of course Artemis and Oliver Queen now
Artemis she's a little more interesting
this is really
um I would say Tom Taylor building on
what's been happening with DC Comics
over the last few years as far as
Artemis goes that the idea behind her
character is that she was an Amazon that
ultimately ended up making her way out
into the larger superhero Community not
really in an identical way to Wonder
Woman and of course she fought alongside
Red Hood in the Outlaws which was an
amazing comic in DC rebirth oh my God
Red Hood oh you guys remember that Red
Hood in the Outlaws from DC rebirth dude
that story was amazing DC is absolutely
jumped the shark in recent years but
back when DC rebirth was dude everything
was the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth I'm just saying like the stories
were absolutely amazing but of course
they basically fire off the Euros to you
know it's kind of a funeral pyre for for
Wonder Woman and that's when Aries the
God of War shows up now under normal
circumstances when Aries shows up it's
because he's looking to start some stuff
right kind of stir that pot a little bit
get conflict Bruin by feeding off the
conflicts of people inciting them into
war with each other different things
like that but the thing about this is
that with his arrival the themiscarians
absolutely like immediately turn on him
right the Amazon's like turn on this guy
and they're like you're not welcome here
you don't need to be here but of course
he tells them like I am not here to be
your enemy I'm not here to incite
conflict or to incite war and yes myself
and Wonder Woman were massive enemies
over the years but one I'm here to pay
my respects to an honorable Warrior and
two you I basically am enlisting you
guys in a gigantic conflict that's going
on I will show you what's happening and
so what he does is he brings all of them
to the Hall of the Gods and of course he
basically ends up giving the arrow of
Apollo to Oliver Queen right to Green
Arrow which is cool right because he
basically gets the bow of a God now of
course he says the weight feels a little
off can I tweak it and the response of
Aries is just like can you tweak the
golden bow of Apollo a bow that hunted
the great beasts of of cocoon whatever
uh that slew the Leviathan lion and he's
and Oliver's like yeah man it's a little
top heavy and he's like fine you know
you can tweak it so one of the things I
love about Tom Taylor writing is he kind
of has the ability to sort of inject
humor with characters that you wouldn't
normally expect to be humorous Ares is
never really a humorous guy right he's
never really the guy where like he jokes
and you know and makes little comments
and stuff but it's more the context of
the situation that makes the whole thing
funny but the reality is that when when
they ask Aries what is it that you want
from us right like why did you bring us
here and so what Aries says is there's a
war coming right now of course Cassie
sandsmark who was at one point Wonder
Woman literally says like we just had a
war now now you're here billions died
before this and this is where things get
crazy because what Aries says is that
was the war there was no struggle there
was only defeat I am not the god of
Slaughter and that's an important
distinction to understand here right
when you look at the entirety of
deceased it is kind of easy to look at
that and it's like it's a war of the the
survivors versus the ones who are
infected but that's not how it played
out remember back in like the first DC
story what happened people got infected
and the world ended like over the course
of the first like the original story arc
the original DC story arc that happened
if I remember over the course of like a
few days like maybe a week or two but
the world collapsed almost immediately
it was literally just people being
infected and the superheroes fleeing for
their lives because the infection had
spread so incredibly fast really thanks
to the flash you've been infected that
there was nothing anybody could do you
right so the superheroes were just
trying to save who they could where they
could and got out as fast as they can
right there was no war it was just
people fleeing for their lives and so
that's literally what he's saying now
and of course what is kind of nuts is he
says that it's not just a war that's
coming but it's a war that cannot be won
the final war right it will be glorious
but ultimately futile I will stay to
watch the end but every race in the
universe will die and so when the
questions asked how can you be so
certain of our failure and he says
because all of this has happened before
and that's what's so cool about this
right this it's literally Battlestar
Galactica all of this has happened
before and all of it will happen again
he says this is how the entire universe
was infected and so where Oliver asked
the question like Aries presents a book
to him right and says this is how things
unfolded before the response of Oliver
Queen is the most logical one where he's
like okay so if what you're holding is a
record book right a book that says like
this is how things transpired before
somebody had to have survived to tell
the tale which means if there was one
Survivor there was more than one
Survivor otherwise every race would have
just died out for no other reason than
the fact that they can't procreate
anymore right so that means if there
were survivors then the question has to
be asked how did we survive this last
time and the response of Aries is no one
did this is a record from a universe
that was lost right a universe that was
completely and totally lost and so at
that moment you basically have Dinah
who's basically the green Canary right
she got a Green Lantern ring that she's
contacted by the Guardians of the
universe who were just like we're
calling every single Green Lantern
Across the Universe back to OHA we're
forming a staging ground right we're
going to use owa as a Battleground to
figure out how we can defeat all these
different Undead folks who are out there
and that's that's when Aries says it
begins right and so literally this goes
out to everyone out there right Kyle
Raynor Jon Stewart like kilowog the
whole nine yards Guy Gardner who's out
there every single Green Lantern not
only that the response of the Guardians
on OA is like bring everybody who is an
ally everybody who's alive any
able-bodied man and woman who can fight
that has any measure of power bring them
to owa right every superpowered being in
the universe is coming here if we can
find some way to Stage to you know keep
this conflict from spreading beyond what
it already is but the funny thing here
is kind of jumping back to Aries the
response of Oliver Queen is well things
are different now when the whole event
first kicked off we had no idea what was
going on but now we have a cure we have
the ability to cure everybody like
Oliver's stance is like we've basically
already won the only issue that we have
now is how do we get a cure to everybody
out there in order to turn them back to
normal and the response of Aries is
you're not fighting an equation right
and that's when when like Donna or I'm
sorry Cassie Chimes and it says yeah but
Dark Side set and Aries response is dark
side is a new God he's a child right a
powerful Pawn for something much larger
he had no idea what he was doing when he
merged the anti-life equation with death
The Gaze has been turned towards us
that's the real threat he says this is
no equation this is older than numbers
older than the gods the universe will
die and he says
erebos is here right so Erebus is this
being this basically behind all of this
right this is the force that was
Unleashed now from here we switch over
to one of the coolest parts of the story
right one of the coolest parts of this
that what is up happening here is Alfred
initially has these Visions where if you
recall in the first DC story he was
forced to kill Batman and Tim Drake and
Dick Grayson he was forced to kill these
guys so the only person that was really
left here was basically Damian Wayne now
if I recall correctly I don't remember
off the top of my head I want to say
that red hood survived but I can't
remember I know he was part of one of
the tie-in stories so if you guys recall
down in the comment section let me know
I could look it up but like I'm in the
middle of recording this right now so
you know I'm I'm a single task person I
don't do very well when it comes to
multitasking but course all these
visions and everything kind of wake
Alfred up out of his sleep and he's
basically they're accompanied by Leslie
Tompkins now Leslie Tompkins had for the
longest time been an ally of Batman she
was kind of comparable to Night Nurse
from Marvel Comics she is much older
than that but or at least have been
around longer than that but the idea
behind Leslie is she was the one that
would tend to the wounds of Batman if he
needed it or she would help other
members of the superhero Community
depending on the circumstance she was a
very significant character in the Batman
Mythos over the years she lost that
level of importance in DC Comics and
it's just kind of been relegated to a
background character so one of the cool
things about Tom Taylor's run is that he
has sort of bolstered her presence back
up to being a significant member of the
bat family even if it's only here to be
a love interest and somebody to comfort
Alfred but the thing about this is that
when Damien and Jonathan tell Alfred
they have to leave that they have to go
join the Guardians of the Galaxy and I'm
sorry the Guardians of the universe in
order to deal with this massive threat
of the undead Armada that initially
Alfred begs Damien not to go right he's
like please please don't leave I already
lost your father I already lost what
were basically my sons I don't want to
lose another son again but the reality
of Damien and this really shows how much
he's changed so it's like the initial
outbreak happened and how he's really
become a hero that stepping into this
role his response to Alfred is this is
much bigger than me right it's much
bigger than you this is literally the
fate of the universe and if I can die in
order to save the universe then it's a
death worth having I don't want to I'm
not going into this with the expectation
that I die but if I do it will be for a
great cause and so the response of
Alfred and this is incredibly important
here because I have a theory about this
I don't know if it's actually happened
yet but I have a theory about this the
response of Alfred is if I can't get you
to stay here then I want to fight
alongside all of you right I want to
fight alongside you guys in defeating
these Undead Gods they've taken so much
from me and I don't want to sit on the
sidelines and basically do nothing and
the response of of Damien is you really
want to fight against the these guys and
the response with Alfred is yes you have
to find a way a weapon a power a ring
and whatever it is I want to fight I
don't want to sit uselessly on the
sidelines now of course this leads to
Damien and Jonathan taking their leave
and ultimately going but it's really not
without Damien saying like you say that
there's so much of my father and me I
say there's a lot of my father in you
because he would he would he would say
the same thing right if he were in your
position he would say like I don't want
to sit on the sidelines if for whatever
reason Bruce Wayne was incapable of
operating his Batman say he was
wheelchair-bound or something like that
and didn't have a suit that could
compensate by giving him the ability to
move that he would simply say like I
want I want to do something I want to be
able to fight in some capacity or maybe
Batman's like 90 years old like he is in
Batman Beyond right he's like a million
years old and just grizzled and just
this crotchety old son of a gun in the
bat cave but still you know it's one of
those things because my theory here is
that Alfred is going to become a Green
Lantern I don't know that's gonna happen
but I think Alfred's gonna be a Green
Lantern and the reason why I say that is
if you guys remember Tom Taylor's
Injustice Alfred took a pill that gave
him the powers of Superman and beat the
crap out of Superman and rescued Batman
from almost being killed by Superman and
then took Batman out of the bat cave and
just left Superman there but Tom Taylor
has a way of always like giving Alfred
some kind of power right giving Alfred
some kind of an ability at this point we
switch over to almarak now I'm gonna be
honest with you guys man we're basically
shown Maxima right now here's the thing
anybody who's been reading DC Comics for
any measure of time probably had the
same response that I did were you like
maximum she hasn't been relevant since
like the days when Superman died which
is true so the idea behind Maxima and
it's one of the most crazy things the
idea behind Maxima is that DC was tired
of the idea of like Batman I'm sorry uh
almost said Batman a Superman they were
tired of the idea of like uh of Superman
and Lois Lane and so the idea of Maxima
is that their her and Superman were
genetically compatible and so what that
meant is that she could give Superman
like the perfect kids right Superman
didn't want to marry her and didn't want
to have any kids with her so he
ultimately rejected her but it was an
attempt by by DC Comics to create a new
love interest for superman but the thing
about this is that uh she hasn't been
relevant since she appeared in a couple
different Comics here and there but like
literally no one cared right this is
spelling oh cool maximum whatever man
and just keep turning the page so it is
interesting to see her here but much
like her complete and total level of
irrelevance in DC Comics she's also
irrelevant here because her planet is
attacked by dark side and the undead
Armada and they're all conquered and
that's the story of her so of course
what we end up doing here is jumping
back to owa and like the coming together
of all the Guardians of the universe as
well as all the superheroes who are here
now the now everybody like all the
superpower survivors or any able-bodied
person who can fight this is numbered
potentially in the billions right just
this massive crowd being addressed by
the Guardians and what they say is that
the undead Armada has already taken 12
planets right these 12 planets have been
seized completely and totally raised and
their their occupants or their races
converted into members of the undead and
it's just spreading like a plague right
their numbers are growing at an
exponential rate one person bites two
those two by four those four by eight
those eight by sixteen you understand
what I'm saying like it's just moving
and it's just moving so fast and
spreading across the universe so quickly
that the response to the Guardians is
there's only one thing we can do here
right like another seven planets with
species clearly seen by as assets by the
anti-life equation have been infected so
now we're at 19 and he says we are
sanctioning lethal Force these infected
worlds have to be wiped away now this is
an important distinction because
traditionally the Green Lanterns are
peacekeeping Force One of the rules that
was laid down when it came to the
Guardians of the universe is the Green
Lanterns could not take lies in more
recent years in DC Comics that changed
during Jeff John's run on Green Lantern
with the Sinestro core War it was one of
the massive moments of the conflict
because like the Sinestro core the
yellow lanterns are just like wiping out
Green Lanterns everywhere they find them
because Sinestro knows like the Green
Lanterns can't harm anybody in that way
they can't end the life and so literally
in the middle of this battle the
Guardians are like we have no choice and
all these Green Lantern rings start
lighting up with a statement lethal
force is now sanctioned and like the
tide turns like that like it's just it's
nuts the Green Lanterns are like it's
all like Donkey Kong and they just start
they start taking it to the to the the
celestial Court God that story is so
good it was so phenomenal but the thing
about this is that in response to this
of course Superman who's now cured of
the anti-life virus and his son Jonathan
do exactly what you would expect him to
which is say we can't wipe out these
worlds we have a cure we should be
focusing on how to cure these people in
terms of wiping these people out now
there are moral arguments on both sides
and reasonable arguments on both sides
The Stance of Superman and Jonathan is
the preservation of Life helping people
as opposed to ending people but Brainiac
and these guys who are survivors and
have Allied themselves against the
anti-life virus their response is the
the possible risk of going to the
anti-life Armada and trying to inject
people with a cure the risk is too great
because all that would have to happen is
Jonathan Kent or Superman or some other
being out there with Incredible levels
of power or Brainiac with his incredible
intellect all they all will happen is
they're turned and it's game over right
like The Dominoes fall and it's the end
of everything the risk is too great The
only thing that we can really do in
order to bring this thing to an end is
to eradicate hate everybody there so
it's a it's it's there's reasonable
arguments on both sides right sometimes
the risk of the Cure is worse than the
disease so you just wipe out the disease
which also includes wiping people out so
it's one of those weird situations where
you can kind of create arguments on both
sides but of course one ends up
happening is Superman responds kind of
uncharacteristically by lashing out and
in fact attacking ganthe right just like
punching this guy right just like
knocking this guy out because literally
ganthin is just like if you stand
against us and everybody else who's
joined you we will destroy you like
we'll lock you up in a prison that'll be
the end of it and we will go and take
out these worlds and so Superman
attacking gamthet is not something that
you normally see and so it's kind of
weird because while all this is
happening we end up finding out Aries is
basically watching all of this unfold
and what's so interesting about this is
that it's actually Damien Wayne who
picks up on what's Happening he's
looking around at this whole situation
and how quickly everybody went crazy and
all started attacking each other and his
response is something's wrong right like
I can feel it my pulse is elevated my
judgment's clouded my emotional response
is heightened we are not in control of
this situation and that's when he sees
Aries and realizes Aries is kind of
goating them all into fighting each
other because Aries is the god of war
and and it's just kind of into that cool
stuff now of course literally Damien
says like you're manipulating us God of
War and the response of Aries is I just
gave you all A little nudge Damien says
stop this and then a voice comes out of
nowhere and says you should listen to
that little man Aries this voice is
coming from Mr mixopitalic he says I
won't let you hurt Superman the fifth
dimensional imp where the power of a God
is here Mr mixopitalic this guy can
alter reality on a whim so the real
question you have to ask here is what
would happen in deceased if Mr
mixopitalic is converted to an undead
God what would happen there because all
he has to do is Alter reality and it's
the end of everything what's going on
guys this is Rob and the ending of this
video is going to be crazy but we are
back with deceased which technically
we're not supposed to release until
later on this week but I want to release
it today so what we end up doing here is
again picking up on Earth 2 which in the
world of deceased is basically just
another Earth or another world within
the DC Universe that is habitable for
Humanity I know for all you guys out
there who are DC aficionados and some of
you all have been asking this in the
comments is it Earth 2 in like an
alternate universe no it's not the
traditional alternate reality Earth too
it's just like a world over that way
that basically allows Humanity to live
on it right because it's sustainable
it's a human life we're conducive to
human life so what we end up getting
here while all these different
superheroes are basically marshalling
their forces working alongside the Green
Lanterns the Guardians of the universe
is we end up having the arrival of the
black racer the black racer is basically
an aspect of death so much like you have
in Marvel Comics where you have like
mistress death in DC Comics you have
death of the Endless so it is an actual
kind of cosmic entity if you want to
call it that uh that represents what it
means to officially die right like your
soul leaves your body and you go on to
the afterlife but death of the Endless
rarely ever actually interacts with
anybody instead what she basically does
is she largely has avatars so if we take
like the Green Lanterns for example
necron is the avatar for the Green
Lanterns themselves technically
represents death in the emotional
Spectrum but nonetheless right it
represents like the lack of life but in
effect it is the aspect of death of the
Endless dead deals with the Green
Lanterns the black flash deals with the
flash family and all the speedsters the
black racer deals with the new gods and
everybody else just dies and their soul
just goes to the afterlife so that's
kind of how these things work right so
they're so again it's really more just
like imagine it was like death of the
Endless just kind of like removes parts
of ourselves and says you're gonna hang
out with the Green Lanterns you're gonna
hang out with the flashes and you're
gonna hang out with the new gods and
that's basically how this works right so
Governors they basically deal with the
flesh or deal with death but the way
this thing shows up is we kind of only
get really black racer for a moment or
two technically it's statement is that
these superheroes can't kill it which
leads us into mixy Mr mixopitalic some
guy's been commenting down in the videos
and been saying that like I've been
pronouncing his name wrong don't care
here's the thing right mix a pedal like
this guy's wildly powerful right he is
immensely powerful the guy's a reality
Warfare right a fifth dimensional length
there's nothing Beyond his ability to
achieve that's one of the more
significant things about his character
and it's why him showing up here is a
pretty big deal I mean you do have Aries
who's kind of thumping his chest you
know in the face of Mixie but the truth
about this is Aries would never stand a
chance against this guy nobody in this
universe would right he's just that
powerful one of the other funny things
is that the conversation that goes on is
that you have the Guardians of the
universe who are directly speaking with
the superheroes and the superheroes talk
about how Erebus is the one that's
basically behind all of this stuff that
when deceased initially kicked off it
really just kind of seemed like it was
dark side basically merging the
anti-life equation with the concept of
death and that gave us all these people
who were infected with anti-life the
Revelation that we learned recently is
that Erebus is some kind of entity that
exists out there that we don't really
know anything about but it's just kind
of been moving from Universe to Universe
wiping out everything in existence by
basically spreading anti-life or by
somebody doing what Darkseid did and
inviting irobos into the universe but
the way that it's talked about here
Erebus seems more like a presence or a
concept or an ideology as opposed to a
physical being that exists out there
again we don't really know anything
about it and we're we'll probably figure
out as time goes on but the Guardians of
the universe are aware of what Erebus is
but that's why I say it's one of those
weird things because you don't really
see Superman asking a question like are
you familiar with his name right or like
her name you never really see them
actually given a pronoun it's more just
sort of spoken indirectly right like you
know this name that kind of a thing so
that's why I say it may or may not be
like a physical tangible being as much
as an ideology but the response of
gamthet here is that if Erebus is at the
heart of this then it changes everything
the core cannot be used to wipe away
infected planets all Green Lanterns are
to guard owa the central power battery
must be protected at all costs now this
is an important distinction to
understand here and the reason why is
because remember the central power
battery is the source of power for the
Green Lanterns themselves but it does
this by tapping into the emotional
Spectrum so if you can consider this as
kind of a link right sort of a chain you
have the emotional Spectrum which
channels the power of willpower into the
Green Lantern central power battery
which in turn is channeled into the
Green Lanterns if any of the Green
Lanterns were presumably corrupted by
irobos that would allow it to enter into
the emotional spectrum and by doing so
spread through the emotional spectrum
and basically corrupt it all right like
willpower fear the whole nine yards it
would dominate all life the thing that's
not really said here by Tom Taylor and
really my assumption here is that the
emotional Spectrum as we know exists on
a multiversal level which means every
universe that exists out there can tap
into the emotional Spectrum we've known
that ever since War of the first
lanterns during Jeff John's run on the
Green Lantern storyline and so what this
would mean is that if Erebus was able to
access the emotional Spectrum it could
actually conquer the entirety of the
Multiverse in one Fell Swoop and that
would be nuts right so it's one of those
things where it's like to keep this guy
from contaminating all creation across
all existence in the Multiverse we have
to stop in here or at least no Green
Lantern can directly come into contact
with now the other part of this is
Damien right operating as Batman asked
the question you guys watched the
universe and everything that goes on can
you show us where the spread is Right
show us what the front lines look like
so we know where to send the most
capable heroes or where we should focus
our energies at and the response of
ganthin is like are you serious the
front lines are everywhere man like this
is not some this is not some conflict
we're like Darkseid and his forces are
going from this planet to that planet to
that planet they're not following a
linear progression that's what makes the
virus just grow at a geometric rate is
they spread out like a plague and they
conquer a variety of planets all at one
time right they literally just jump from
World of world and they all do it and
that's what leads to the virus spreading
so fast because what he does is he shows
them a world called balavox Vic which is
basically a world that belongs to
kilowatt but there's 16 billion people
on this planet these 16 billion people
just as an example if they were
conquered and taken over by the
anti-life virus using the power of the
anti-light virus and the fact that
they're basically dead they can breathe
in the vacuum of space they would spread
out to the stars and who knows how many
other worlds they would hit but another
world with 10 billion people on it
another world with 5 billion people and
suddenly that Collective 15 billion
people is combined with the 16 billion
people and you've got 31 billion people
traveling around the cosmos conquering
world you guys see what I'm talking
about and you see why the universe fell
so fast when it came to the anti-life
virus that it's just one of those things
where everything grows at an exponential
rate and so what ends up happening here
is that as they're talking you end up
having gantted that says that they have
to reform the quintessence of course the
quintessence being some of the most
powerful beings are really the most
powerful beings throughout the entirety
of the DC Universe but the problem here
is that it's literally figured things
out by committing somebody like Guy
Gardner doesn't want to have to deal
with that he's like that's ridiculous
I'm not going to sit around while you
guys vote by committee to figure out
whether or not the universe is worth
saving we're gonna get out there and
we're gonna fight and ultimately the
hands of the Guardians are tied if the
Guardians were for example to shut down
the central power battery and take away
the Green Lantern's source of power then
what happens if the anti-life virus
reaches owa and the Guardians aren't
there there's no one to protect it all
the Green Lanterns fall the central
power battery is left without any form
of protection and then it's game over
right it's just that kind of thing so
honestly what really ends up happening
here is the Green Lanterns actually
leave with kilowatt when he takes off to
go to his home planet in order to
basically try to save his people and
then you have like Mixie and then
Superman and Jonathan Kent now Jonathan
Kent wants to go with Superman to fight
in this battle but the response to
Superman is no like that's not going to
be the case right he literally says this
is one planet right you saw the
guardian's vision there are dozens of
planets that need us billions of lives
being threatened as we speak I wish I
could take you with me keep you near me
keep you safe but I need you to protect
our Two Earths I need you to start
saving the planets the Guardians have
given up on so it's a really significant
moment and the reason why is because in
recent years especially if you go back
to what is it the Superman Lois and
Clark comic book by Dan Jurgens where
they basically brought back the free
flashpoint Superman bet Jonathan Kent
was a little kid even going into like
super sons and different stories like
that Action Comics rebirth Superman
rebirth it was largely Superman trying
to protect his son but ever since Brian
Michael bendis's trash ass run on
Superman where basically he aged up uh
Jonathan can't turn him into a teenager
which was what nobody wanted to have
happen but bendus did it anyway because
that guy just doesn't know how to write
Superman but it basically led to
Superman kind of having to take a more
hands-off approach to Jonathan Kemp this
kind of conversation is honestly the
sort of stuff that we should have been
seeing during bendis's run it's less of
Superman trying to protect his son and
it's more Superman trying to teach his
son to be a more effective hero it's
what we saw during Action Comics rebirth
and Superman rebirth which were amazing
stories just kind of a Sidetrack here if
you ever want to know what some of the
best Superman stories were in recent
years check out the videos that I did on
Action Comics and Superman rebirth
they're phenomenal oh my God those
stories were amazing but the thing here
is that ultimately Jonathan Kent just
kind of has to stay behind and Superman
takes off along with kilowog and
everybody else to arrive on his planet
now the funny thing about this is that
for the people of kilowog they share a
kind of hive mind right which is to say
they're highly empathetic and they can
feel the emotions of every other member
on their race and so the result of this
is that when kilowatt gets there his
mind basically rejoins the collective
and all he feels is absolute Terror now
if you're not familiar with kilowog and
the Green Lanterns This Moment's lost on
you but if you are familiar with kilowog
it's huge and the reason why for those
of you guys who really aren't familiar
with this character kilowatts hardcore
man he's like the drill instructor for
the Green Lantern court but this guy
he's got it where it counts and if
you're stranded out there by yourself
kilowog is really the guy you'd want
coming to your side the fact that he's
quite literally shivering in his boots
right now is a testament to the terror
he feels connected with the rest of his
people and the terror they feel which is
being fed into him but his his kind of
emotional state is bolstered when you
get the arrival of the rest of the Green
Lanterns but this is important because
remember the Green Lanterns derive their
abilities from the will will power
portion of the emotional Spectrum the
more willpower they have the more
capable they are the less willpower they
have meaning their confidence begins to
wane the less capable they are so
without the other Green Lantern showing
up here there's a better than fair
chance that literally kilowog would have
just been annihilated because at the end
of the day his willpower just wouldn't
have been where it traditionally would
have been because of the fear that he
was feeling right just the weakness of
the Green Lanterns and so what you have
is of course you have the Green Lanterns
you've got Superman you got all these
guys who are trying to protect the
people of kilowog as best they can enter
Supergirl now the funny thing about this
is that Superman has not met Supergirl
yet remember like during the deceased in
in this story in this universe Supergirl
never crash landed on earth right she
was never sent there instead she was
sent to the world of the new Gods she
was sent to uh new genesis where High
father was to reside but by the time she
got there they'd already been infected
with the anti-life virus so as soon as
she got there she was immediately
subdued and taken over she didn't stand
a chance Superman's never seen her
before and that's why he asked the
question who are you why are you wearing
that symbol and so the result of this is
that she's able to annihilate some of
the people on this world Superman's kind
of hopeless to Stand By and Watch
because out of nowhere comes Darkseid
and Supergirl just kind of watches on as
Darkseid intends to thrash Superman
enter Mixie right Mr mix pitlick himself
dude it's so cool to see this guy right
this there's never been a time that I'm
aware of in DC Comics when Mixie is
fought dark side I'm not aware of that
at all but we get this amazing moment
here right literally he says okay that's
enough new God what should I turn you
into a houseplant a persuasive essay and
it says all mixy had to do was think it
and Darkseid would have been undone but
he didn't have time to think and this is
one of the things to remember right
remember how the anti-life equation
initially spread throughout Earth
remember how it started smartphones TVs
tablets people saw it they witnessed the
equation and in doing so they were
corrupted by it and that's literally
what Tom Taylor says right the virus
spread in two ways and while Mixie was
no doubt confident he couldn't be harmed
which he couldn't be hurt by Darkseid he
could still see and all it took was a
corrupted Mother Box to show him the
anti-life equation and its game over
Mixie is infected like that right he's
the most powerful force under control of
the anti-life equation right now this
guy could literally undo everybody with
just a thought now this is the way that
Tom Taylor plays this and I actually
like the way that he does this under any
normal circumstance if mixy was
basically full of his own capabilities
right meaning he had his own he had he
had his own mind and he was operating
rationally and stuff like that there's
no limit to the kind of stuff he can do
what it looks like the anti-life
equation does is it kind of reduces
people down to a more primitive state so
he's not as capable as he normally would
be now whether or not this is something
you agree with depends on you know on on
how you feel like the story should end
right like your own personal opinions
will infer whether or not you agree with
this kind of thing which makes sense
right I mean everybody interprets
stories in their own way but the real
here is that instead of Nixie just
napping his fingers and everybody turns
into like a bouquet of roses he
literally just like starts attacking
everyone now kilowog and Jon Stewart
respond as soon as it happens but Mixie
immediately like seizes control of him
the former protective orb as best they
can it gets crushed Jon Stewart and
kilowatt die like that like they're just
dead gone out of the picture it's one of
the reasons why I love Tom Taylor's
writing when it comes to this stuff man
is because at any point in time any
superhero can die it's one of the
greatest things about his writing when
it comes to these alternate reality
stories because by and large when it
comes to DC no matter what happens in a
story like Superman will always come out
on top right the Green Lanterns will
eventually always come out on top it's
always that way right it's just the
superheroes always win it's just how
long will it take them to win and what
will they have to go through until they
do when it comes to these alternate
reality stories by Tom Taylor anything
goes right like there's no rules and
it's the reason why these stories that
he does are so phenomenal right they're
absolutely amazing because basically
with this world destroyed and Mixie
Unleashed he he immediately takes off
for the world of owa and when he gets
there he annihilates the central power
battery and we get this amazing point
where it's like and everywhere Green
Lanterns were severed from their power
exposing the core to gravity and to the
vacuum of space they're literally just
suffocating out there with no oxygen
whatsoever right it's almost like from
Injustice when Kyle Raynor was pulled
apart by the by the celestial core and
dropped into the sun right just like
killed in space it was pretty gruesome
right it was pretty brutal but the thing
about this is that while the
quintessence meets you've got Hera of
the Greek gods you've got the Phantom
stranger who even goes as far as to say
like the wizard Shazam is dead High
father is a slave to the anti-life
equation I was almost destroyed by
Trigon fighting this which I'm not aware
that we ever actually got a story where
the Phantom stranger fought Trigon and
if we didn't we need that maybe I'm
missing something if I am let me know
down in the comments because maybe it's
a story that we didn't cover and if we
didn't we will fix that with a quickness
let me know like let me know down in the
comment section what's going on but the
bigger point of the Phantom strangers
making is the quintessence since numbers
are decreasing this universe will likely
be lost to Erebus but the response of
the Specter right the living embodiment
of God's Vengeance wrath whatever you
want to call it like literally they kind
of refer to it as both his response is
I'm not going to let this universe fall
I'm not going to let another Universe
fall to araba so he literally takes off
and then suddenly the power of the Green
Lanterns starts to restore but it starts
to come back and we end up finding out
the reason why is because the Specter
sees control of the central power
battery of the Green Lanterns
reconstituted it and wielding the power
of the Green Lanterns and The Willpower
of emotion of the emotional Spectrum
which will likely lead to him becoming a
Green Lantern he Fashions the sword of
God and then goes after Mixie and that's
the end thanks for watching guys no this
is actually the Cliffhanger though right
so in the next video we will cover what
happens next what's going on guys this
is Rob and we are back with deceased and
I am coming down with a cold so I may
not necessarily be as crazy and animated
as I normally am but as is the case with
a Tom Taylor comic the ending of this is
crazy the that's always the case of Tom
Taylor so what we end up doing here is
we pick up with Superman there is a bit
of a Prelude when it comes to Lobo but
we'll talk about him presumably in the
next issue when he makes his appearance
as part of the main conflict but what
goes on here is it initially picks up
with Superman and this basically deals
with the destruction of ballovax Vic
right now if you guys remember the last
video that we did and as always you'll
find the DC's playlist down in the
description so that if you're just
joining us you can get caught up on
everything but as we talked about in the
last video this was destroyed by Mr
mixopitalic who is one of the most
powerful beings to ever exist in the
history of DC Comics and the fact that
this guy has now been turned to the army
of the dead right like the the army of
dark side right the undead Army it
changes everything because Mr
mixopolittle like this guy can also
reality just with a snap of his fingers
this guy can go toe-to-toe with the most
powerful beings that exist out there in
DC and so this is kind of a worst case
scenario we don't know the full totality
of his abilities and we don't even know
if he can access his true power anymore
but the important thing here is that
with Mr mixolitic becoming part of the
undead Army he destroyed the planet of
bolivax Vic now there are a couple
reasons why the superheroes even
responded to this world in the first
place when the undead Army was heading
there there's really only two main
reasons the first is because of kilowog
who's a member of the Green Lantern
Corps and the fact that it's his own
home planet and it's more or less the
Green Lantern saying we will Ally with
you because you're one of us and we'll
do everything we can to protect your
home world the other part of this was
just self-preservation bolivax Vic is
home to 16 billion people with a B
you're talking about an army so vast
that it bolsters the existing vastness
of darkseid's Army and makes Conquering
the universe all the easier and so for
the for everybody who really wasn't a
Green Lantern and didn't really even
know kilowog on a personal level it
really required their intervention
because had they not stepped in
presumably 16 billion foes or 16 billion
people or so would have bolstered the
army of Darkseid such as it was they're
all dead right so I guess it's kind of a
zero sum now if you're a person who
lacks empathy like hey dead man can't
fight a war so that's basically what
this is now but at the end of the day
there is a bit of somberness that comes
in the aftermath of this and the
destruction of this entire world hits
Superman hard because for the second
time over the course of DC's and even
the second time in his life in this
alternate reality story he has to
basically watch a world fall the first
time it happened was when the outbreak
happened on earth right when like
everybody on Earth was either becoming
infected or they were killed or they
managed to escape they managed to flee
but like that was it right human like
Humanity just regular people there was
no real hope for them there was no real
saving them and so Superman did what he
could where he could but even he fell to
the power of the undead of the the
anti-life virus and so when that
happened of course ultimately he was
saved hence the reason why he's here now
but this is the second time he has to
watch that happen now one of the funny
things about this is that it's easy to
look at Tom Taylor's writing and see him
as a guy who's really just kind of
writing off Superman as like in
incompetent right or a guy who just
can't really do anything effective in
this universe because he sucks but
that's not really the case the truth
about it is you kind of have to look at
the actions of Superman both in a micro
and a in a macro sense when it comes to
like Superman operating in a micro sense
he's in Metropolis and sometimes there's
foes around the world that he faces off
against and that's it but when it comes
to Superman operating on a macro level
right on a great big huge larger level
especially in a universal space he can't
be everywhere at once and he can't save
everybody all at once despite Superman
almost appearing as this kind of Larger
than Life figure he's not he's just a
person who's got some powers and he's
really capable and he does cool stuff
sometimes and that's it and so it's one
of those really cool ways to kind of
bring his character down and remind us
as the reader this guy's not some
Unstoppable force and watching a world
perish when he feels like he could have
done something to save them it hits them
all the harder not only that you've also
got Kyle Raynor who's struggling here
right now remember Kyle Raynor is one of
the four Green Lanterns of Earth you've
got Kyle Rayner Guy Gardner Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart Jon Stewart and kilowatt
are dead right they're out so literally
like Kyle Raynor is watching the people
that he calls friends perish right in
front of his eyes and so it's really
just one of these instances where this
destruction of this world happened at
such a time to where it strikes a
massive moral blow at the superhero
Community but here's the beauty of
Superman right Superman is pissed this
guy is incensed and in fact despite the
fact that they're seemingly so far away
from each other both he and Darkseid
lock eyes on each other and for a moment
Superman is ready to race off and face
off against Darkseid directly but if he
did that he would fail there'd be no way
for him to come out on top of that fight
assuming that it's just him and Darkseid
it's literally Dark Side empowered by a
Yellow Lantern ring he's a member of the
Sinestro court that doubles the amount
of power that he normally has he would
absolutely Crush Superman now when you
add in the fact that members of the the
undead Army include Supergirl Kara
zorrell who's more powerful than
Superman is than all these other
different individuals out there all of
whom have different varying levels of
power sometimes comparable to Superman
sometimes a little less powerful in the
case of Mr mixopitalic even more
powerful no way this guy would win it
would literally be a Fool's Aaron it's a
suicide run and so he does the next best
thing he literally takes all that anger
he channels it inward he tells Kyle it's
not lost we can still do something he
turns it into hope and that's the power
of Superman the power of Superman is
that all the anger and the rage that we
as people would normally feel and we
would spew that anger and rage out into
the world on Twitter or Reddit or
something like that and do nothing to
make the world better Superman does the
opposite Superman's response is like yes
I'm full of anger and I'm full of grief
and I'm full of sadness but I'm going to
channel that into something productive
right I'm going to become like I'm going
to do something good with it and then he
goes out and does that and so again it's
one of the one of the small differences
and really kind of the Hallmark of what
makes Superman Superman that so
following that if we switch over to Mr
mixopitalic and the Specter now this is
a fight for the ages right this is a
massive battle a really good example of
this if you're familiar with Marvel
Comics it would be like Protege versus
The Living Tribunal right Protege has
the power to copy the powers of anyone
he sees and there's no limit to the
level of power that he can copy so much
so that he became as powerful as the
Living Tribunal it's like these two guys
facing off against each other you could
only imagine the level of power that's
being displayed here like quite
literally they're creating black holes
they're tearing in the very fabric of
space the impact of their punches is
enough to shatter the planets around
them right like suns are going Supernova
it's crazy how intense this battle is
now the Green Lanterns try as they might
fire off their Green Lantern rings they
try to restrain Mr Mitchell pitolic he
kills every last one of them and by all
standards of measurement this is a
losing battle right it is a losing fight
the the average person cannot possibly
stand a chance to even hold their own in
a battle between these two Titans so it
really just comes down to Mr mixopitalic
and the Specter to see who ends up
winning but here's where everything goes
south yet again yes you guys know how it
is with Tom Taylor just when you think
the heroes have a chance to win things
go belly up yet again so Brainiac
basically arrives here now of course
Brainiac has historically been a
Superman villain but in this instance
the enemy of my enemy is my friend the
the desire for self-preservation makes
every Survivor Across the Universe
whether they were former enemies or not
they're all allies now they're all
working together just to try to keep
themselves alive and destroy the undead
Army so Brainiac showing up here is well
one they've already met with him before
but him but two him showing up here and
arriving on Earth too which is kind of
like the backup Earth the second Earth
after the first Earth fell that it is a
way for them to kind of Marshal and
bolster their forces the problem with
this is that the arrival of Brainiac is
met with the arrival of scot-free right
Mr Miracle the guy who can break out of
any prison anywhere the issue with this
is that he is traveling with a mother
box and as soon as Brainiac sees this
he's like that why did you bring that
here because the mother boxes are all
connected he literally tells them it's a
giant Network what you're doing here is
ringing the dinner bell you're telling
everyone that we're here it's like
literally as soon as the mother box
pings and the infected realize where
they are a boom tube opens and they all
come pouring out led by high father
right the leader of the new Gods one of
the most powerful beings out there in DC
and yet another guy whose power
depending on the story rivals or
sometimes even exceeds that of
Superman's so now you have all these new
Gods who are just pouring out onto Earth
too and they're attacking all the
superheroes right like it seems like
it's all going Belly Up you've got
you've got their forces who are showing
up on the scene it's it's open season
right it's a slaughterhouse Humanity
like you have like Batman and you have a
few other people trying to get people
out where they can when they can but one
of the people that falls here is Leslie
Tompkins now I told you guys what was
what was likely going to happen here and
Alfred does not become a Green Lantern
but I told you guys something was going
to happen with Alfred that Alfred was
going to in some capacity be the main
focus of the story or just something
something nuts would take place with him
and so what ends up happening here is
remember Alfred and Leslie Tompkins they
have a relationship together they're in
love right like it's like for the first
time in a long time Leslie represents
the possibility for Alfred being able to
have a happier life after having to kill
Batman when he became infected having to
kill Nightwing and and what was it uh
Tim Drake having to kill him well they
all became infected having to basically
kill his sons it tore him apart but when
Damien Wayne survived and became the new
Batman and Leslie Tompkins fell in love
with Alfred and Alfred fell in love with
her it was a shot at happiness and now
that shot's been ripped away now it's
been pulled away from Alfred so
literally what ends up happening here is
we transitioned back over to the fight
between mixopitalic and the Specter and
so literally what ends up going on here
is Superman realizing all inspector
needs is an opening that's all the
Specter needs is the ability to just get
a shot in that can destroy mixopitalic
Superman hits Mr Mr mixolittle head on
not enough to destroy him but it's
enough to distract him and with that
opening the Specter stabs Mr M Through
the Heart Right Mr Mitchell piddle he
stabs him through the heart but
mixopitalic in turn reaches Into the
Heart of the Specter and rips out Jim
Corgan now Jim Corrigan is the host
because remember when it comes to the
Specter he's just the embodiment of
God's Vengeance or God's Wrath depending
on what comic and what reality the comic
is taking place in but the important
thing here is if the Specter is not
bonded to a host he just kind of floats
out there into The Ether and that's
basically it that you the Specter has to
have somebody to be attached to in order
to be able to act and in order to be
able to do anything there was a story
there have been stories in DC Comics
where the Specter is able to act without
a host but that's not the norm and Tom
Taylor's kind of following the
traditional standard of DC which is the
Spectrum needs the host to do something
and so as Jim Corgan literally laid
dying just out there in space that the
Specter having no host whatsoever Alfred
has to like watch on as Leslie Tompkins
dies and then in turn you basically have
high father who steps in and high father
shows up on the scene Damian Wayne jumps
in to do what he can where he can as
Batman but he's no match for high father
all they're really doing is buying time
here the reality is that high father
will kill them all he will eradicate
every single person here they're all
going to die and in fact when high
father hits Damian Wayne Alfred steps in
and just lets out this unrelenting
scream now here's the thing right this
whole thing is told from the perspective
of Alfred he says I didn't even realize
I'd moved all I knew was there was a
scream a scream I contained when that
little boy lost his parents in an alley
so long ago a scream I held in as I
ended the lives of three men I loved a
scream of defiance of grief but mostly a
fury and in that moment I heard an echo
of my anger across the cosmos there was
a Harmony of rage and Alfred becomes the
new host for the Specter literally out
like Alfred becomes Specter and it is
dope because as soon as that happens the
first thing Alfred does he kills High
father on the spot and if Alfred can
kill High father Alfred can kill
Darkseid and Alfred could quite
literally turn the tie to the war what's
going on guys this is Rob we're back
with deceased and oh my God I can't wait
to see how you guys feel about the
ending of this story it's it's amazing
right the ending of this is just oh my
God I'm so excited for this so as you
guys know with deceased right to get you
guys caught up on everything because
these issues come out once a month so
it's been a little while since we did
the most recent one so as always you'll
find a link to the DC's playlist down in
the description in case you want to get
caught up but we'll also make a full
story video on the whole deceased event
from beginning to end once this whole
thing wraps up but keeping in mind
what's happened been so far is that you
basically have the forces of all those
who are infected by anti-life they're
basically zombies right by all standards
of measurement they're effectively
zombies and they're led by dark side and
they're literally cutting like a swath
through the universe and they're making
their way towards Earth too which is
like the second version of Earth is
basically the the new Earth and all the
different characters of the survivors
basically live on and this battle has
been raging on for a little while right
like it's been going for some time now
at this moment one of the things to
remember is lobo basically steps in now
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Lobo he's amazing but ridiculous at
the same time the idea behind Lobo is he
was designed to be like a DC Comic
parody of Wolverine from Marvel Comics
right they're like Lobos just ridiculous
he's over the top he's nigh
indestructible right it's almost
impossible to hurt this guy if not truly
impossible I mean his healing factors
absurd it's nuts right I mean it's it's
crazy what this guy's capable of the
important thing here though is that
lobo's a guy who is every bit on par
with Superman in terms of power and this
guy's showing up on the scene is a huge
deal because it's not enough to like
turn the entirety of the battle in favor
of the superheroes but it is enough to
help them Stave off their own impending
death a little bit longer but as we know
with deceased this is as much an
analysis of the nature of superheroes as
it is just like an end of the universe
type of event and so what you end up
getting here is of course big Barta and
scot-free right Mr miracle if you're not
familiar with them they're not overly
important the big thing about this
though with their characters is that
they were initially infected a cure has
since been developed but the Cure is on
the old Earth it's not on the new Earth
and so the result is that they don't
have the ability to easily cure people
in this area more so than that while big
Barda and Scott fried were cured their
son Jacob has not been cured and in fact
he's infected now and this is where the
kind of personality driven element of
the story comes into play because one of
the things that happens is while Alfred
pennyworth is basically narrating all
this stuff one of the things he talks
about is that he never really understood
the kind of sacrifice that a parent
would make for their child until he
became apparent himself self having like
Bruce Wayne is kind of a surrogate son
right really his son by all standard of
measurement and that in experiencing
what it meant to have kids of his own he
understands the sacrifice that a parent
would make for their child and so what
he talks about here is that in this
instance Jacob the son of big varda and
scot-free attacks his parents because
they can't bring themselves to kill
their own child now for Alfred himself
right remember he's basically imbued
with the Specter now of course the
Specter is basically the embodiment of
God's Wrath it's one of the cool things
to know about DC Comics is that like
judeo-christianity right it does exist
in DC the god of Abraham the
judeo-christian God does exist in DC
Comics he's called The Presence but the
thing about the Specter is that he is as
much a plot device as he is an essential
character right like he's a guy who
really just kind of shows up whenever
he's needed and sometimes his power is
enough to just end the threat
immediately other times it's not he's
like the Living Tribunal in Marvel
Comics could he just wave his hand and
end the problem sure but like because of
whatever's going on for some reason he
can't and case of Alfred While You know
despite the fact that he's imbued with
all this astronomical power there is a
bit of inner turmoil going on here the
first is that as the the embodiment of
God's Wrath or God's judgment right the
role of the Specter kind of changes
really even just within the confines of
this story it's kind of nuts that his
initial motivation is to just destroy
everything right I mean it's kind of
it's really him fighting against the
nature of the Specter itself that's what
it does it like you know fire Brimstone
the specter's Old Testament man like he
just does that kind of stuff but Alfred
himself even filled with anger and rage
towards those who were basically zombies
and the sensitists because of them that
he lost Bruce Wayne and he lost uh Dick
Grayson and he lost Jason Todd and the
people who are close to him right Damien
Wayne is the only Survivor that's why
he's taking on the mantle of Batman that
in reality Alfred just wants to
annihilate everything but it's kind of
funny because in the midst of all this
fight right this great big huge fight
that's going on Damien Wayne has been
infected and so seemingly it's only a
matter of time before Damien succumbs to
the virus now how fast people succumb to
this is relative to the importance of
the character right like if someone who
doesn't matter is infected with the
virus they turn immediately if it's
somebody like Damien Wayne it's all hold
on as best I can you know and he lasts
just long enough to basically you know
somehow find a way out of it or
something along those lines and so it's
kind of cool here because what you end
up having is Damien speaking directly to
Alfred and this is one of the huge
things that Tom Taylor did with Damien's
character because when Damien was
originally introduced in DC Comics way
back during Grant Morrison's Batman run
during the Batman and Son story arc that
what we had was Damien who was trained
by the League of Assassins and he didn't
really care he would kill anybody for
any crime it didn't matter what it was
right like those of you guys who
remember the movie Batman Begins when
Liam Neeson's character was saying like
we just need to kill anybody who commits
crime because the reality is that the
criminal justice system basically allows
those individuals who commit crimes to
have a second chance and criminals rely
on that second chance to basically
better their abilities to commit crimes
without getting caught that Damien was
very much the same way Damien was like
if you shoplift you're dead right if you
uh if you dive into a pool you're not
supposed to you're dead right for those
of you guys who recognize the tick tock
meme no diving but like it's that kind
of a thing right like Damien was just
super hardcore and in fact even in a lot
of ways it was Batman just having to
reel Damien in it was Batman having to
teach him you don't just kill anybody
because they commit any kind of a crime
the reality here is sometimes you let
the small fish go so they can lead us to
the big fish and other times some crimes
just don't matter right like I mean a
person shoplifted it sucks for the
person who owns the store but in the
grand scheme of all the crime that's
committed in Gotham City it doesn't
really matter all that much and so kind
of reeling Damien in and then at the
same time teaching Damien to kind of
focus on humanity and to focus on the
idea that people can become better hence
the reason why everybody deserves a
second chance that initially Damien
didn't take to it and he very much
rejected it what this story shows is the
evolution of Damien over the years yes
it's an alternate reality story no it
does not take place in the main DC
Universe but the progression and nature
of Damien is still the same and so were
Damien's talking to Alfred and saying
look you can't just kill everybody right
I know you want to I know you desire to
because of all the things that you lost
everything that's been destroyed
everything that you care about Alfred
has been totally destroyed I know that
you are angry hence the reason why you
are now the host of the Specter but you
have to be better than that you can't
destroy everything and even if you
desire to hold off on doing that for me
if you ever loved me and if you ever
respected my memory and what the mantle
of Batman stood for do not go through
and just kill everybody now that's an
important distinction to understand here
because Alfred could do that as the
Specter right he could literally go
through and just annihilate everybody
here and it'd be very very easy for him
to do and so this is one of those things
where like it kind of allows the story
to continue but it focuses more on the
nature of Alfred now for the most part
one of the things that goes on here is
that Alfred starts to realize there's
something much bigger a foot that yes
like Erebus who's kind of like the main
enemy that we haven't really seen yet
but basically the one that is the reason
why this anti-life virus exists in the
first place right so you can kind of
call him the crew creator of the virus
not really patient zero but the main
catalyst behind all this that Erebus
starts to realize the nature of the
heroes that they won't stop fighting
that regardless of what happens they
will eventually find a way to win and so
in order to quell that instead of having
this kind of Battle of attrition where
Erebus is just kind of sending his
forces in over time he sends them all in
at once just this overwhelming force and
it's a really smart move to make because
normally you could go with the Battle of
attrition right you could just have a
virtually endless wave of enemies that
constantly come at you and just wear you
down to the point that you can't
necessarily fight but because the nature
of superheroes is that they are all
effectively Mary sues in the sense that
it's like well Against All Odds will
somehow find a way the best way to
defeat them is to throw all your forces
at them at once such a massive
overwhelming force that there's
seemingly no way to win so not only does
Darkseid and all his forces arrive on
the scene Supergirl the whole nine yards
right because she's infected right so
the other thing that happened is war
world follow suit now war world is a
huge deal for those of you guys who
don't know think of war world and DC
Comics it's very similar to like the
Death Star from Star Wars right one it
is an actual world where people just
fight in gladiatorial and gladiatorial
combat right that's one of the big
things about it but the other part of
war world is it is literally a
destructive vessel right it can just
fire off beams of light that will
eradicate an entire planet right and
that's literally what's going on here
that when War World shows up that Alfred
actually takes off right he literally
leaves and he says like I'm needed
elsewhere right there's somewhere else
that I need to be and that leads to
Jonathan Kent the son of Superman
stepping in now remember Superman
himself is off on the other side of the
universe with the Green Lanterns they
split their forces in half one half was
to go save a world that was being
attacked by dark side lest that world's
population end up being turned and
darkseid's forces bolster by like 16
billion with a beat a massive number and
so splitting those numbers in half you
only have really half the superheroes
that are available fighting here and so
Jonathan stepping in one of the cool
things about his character is much like
Damien's Evolution between being the
just murderous Son of Batman to becoming
an actual superhero Jonathan wasn't
really murderous but he struggled with
confidence he lived under his father's
Shadow right he's the son of Superman
and that in the DC Universe all these
superheroes out there model themselves
in some capacity after Superman he's
like the guy right and so like when
you're the son of Superman you're in the
shadow of presumably the greatest
superhero to ever live and so Jonathan's
Evolution as a character was breaking
out from under his father's Shadow and
becoming his own man and one of the ways
in which he does this is facing off
directly against Darkseid now can
Jonathan defeat Darkseid while
darkseid's empowered by the anti-life
virus as well as a Yellow Lantern ring
which basically allows him to feed on
fear and bolster his power no Jonathan
cannot win under that circumstance one
he's not powerful enough and two
Darkseid is far more capable far more
knowledgeable and a lot more experience
in combat than Jonathan is and so
Brainiac ultimately steps in right
Brainiac being like well technically
he's the ninth level intelligence but a
major super villain and so the result of
this is that because Brainiac is by all
standards of measurement a living
computer that Darkseid infects Brainiac
with the anti-life virus which in turn
leads to Brainiac taking off to his own
ship now the reason why Brainiac does
this ties directly into the nature of
Brainiac remember one of the big things
about his character is that over the
years throughout his entire publication
history in DC Comics this guy travels
from one planet to the next basically
conquering and destroying it but
whenever he does he steals a singular
City from that planet shrinks it down in
order to preserve the knowledge of that
planet and by extension expand his own
knowledge and then he literally just
kind of keeps it as a sort of Trophy and
there are hundreds if not thousands of
these cities because of the amount of
time that Brainiac has spent traveling
the spaceways and conquering worlds and
so when he shows up here that what
Brainiac starts doing is actually just
you know starts destroying each one of
these cities but then cyborg shows up
now under normal circumstances Victor
Stone is about as useless as tits in the
Warhawk this guy never this guy doesn't
do anything right he starts no useful
purpose but in this story he does and
it's a pretty epic one so because of the
fact that Brainiac is a living computer
and Cyborg is quite literally one half
human and one half machine that where
Erebus in control of Brainiac tries to
infiltrate cyborg cyborg realizes Erebus
can't do that cyborg himself is immune
to the anti-life virus now we've known
that since the beginning but we didn't
know the extent of it and so what this
means is that with cyborg being
impenetrable right somebody that Erebus
literally can't get a hold of that what
cyborg does is he seizes control of
brainiac's Prime Systems if you want to
call it that and absorbs brainiac's
Consciousness into himself quite
literally cyborg merges with Brainiac
and what it does is it not only boosts
the intelligence of cyborg giving him a
much more intuitive understanding of
exactly what he needs to do in order for
the superheroes to win but it also
grants him all the knowledge of Brainiac
himself and that's when he comes up with
an idea and he literally travels back to
all the superheroes and he's like Lois
Lane and she's like yes and he's like
where's Candor and as soon as I saw that
I was like oh my God right like oh my
God because I totally forgot about
Candor it never occurred to me to think
about Candor now we'll talk about why
that matters here in a second but
jumping back over to Jonathan Kent and
his fight with Darkseid he's able to
hold his own to a degree but what
happens is something else catches his
attention and what he does is he races
away from the fight and he flies to war
world and the reason why is because he
realizes war world is powering up its
Canon and war world is intending to
annihilate the entirety of the planet
Earth in one Fell Swoop it's a genius
move right send in all the soldiers
right so they're like all the foot
soldiers so that all the superheroes are
distracted and fighting them and in that
distraction use your primary weapon to
take everybody out are some of your
soldiers gonna die sure but if your goal
is to win by any means necessary then of
what relevance are soldiers that you see
is easily replaceable it's diabolical
but it would work and so what's so crazy
about this is that Jonathan is able to
hold off the blast of War World right
saving the Earth but as he falls back to
the planet thousands of kryptonians are
making their way into the battle now
here's the reason why and this is where
it all this is this is where it all gets
nuts Israel gets crazy remember kandor
was a city on Krypton that brainiacs
stole Before krypton's Destruction like
literally kryptonians need to be exposed
to a yellow sun in order for their
powers to thrive and so what happened is
that literally because of cyborg the
various kryptonians in the bottled city
of Candor were freed from their
captivity and returned to their normal
size so now all these kryptonians you
basically have thousands of Superman
just flying around right Superman and
Superwoman this changes the nature of
the battle entirely but but here's the
thing man there's still this amazing
moment that happens to this amazing
moment that comes out right so like
Superman arrives back on this scene
right like him and all the other forces
are basically back in the battle now
Superman of course rescues his son which
is really really cool and then Alfred
returns with the Cure that he took from
like Earth right like literally brought
just these huge shipping containers full
of the Cure and flew it to the other
side of space in order to basically cure
all those who are infected on Earth too
and so of course Damien Wayne is one of
the people who's cured here but the
other person that's cured is dark side
literally it's one of the coolest things
right so like like you literally have
like uh you've got you've got Mary
Marvel right from like shazam's sister
basically she's like holding down Dark
Side Jonathan Ken's holding down dark
side and then like Lobo comes up and
just like grabs one of the uh one of the
Cure virals and like smashes it in the
mouth of Darkseid and cures dark side so
then dark side returns to normal right
and then he's like what's happened and
he's basically told by like Alfred and
Superman you are basically infected with
the anti-life virus you are being used
as a pawn now Alfred immediately wants
to destroy dark side but he wants to
eradicate him but the response of
Superman is no we cannot kill Darkseid
one Dark Side by himself is more than
enough for any one of us here Darkseid
imbued with the power of a Sinestro core
ring a Yellow Lantern ring amplifies his
power even further right like Darkseid
is incensed that Erebus had used him as
a pawn in a campaign to conquer the
universe so what does Darkseid do
Darkseid joins the superheroes and turns
against Erebus and that's the thing man
Erebus has no idea what's coming right
it's like that guy said to John Lithgow
in that movie Ricochet you didn't beat
him you just pissed him off and now you
cause now he's gonna be out for blood so
Batman's son just created a whole
universe and it's amazing check this out
so this is the conclusion for deceased
War of the undead Gods just one of the
best stories that DC Comics has released
in the last like five years it's
absolutely phenomenal so for those of
you guys who are catching up with us at
this point at the end it's now time to
go to war with aerobos now I will make
sense of everything that's going on in
case you're joining us for the very
first time but again this is fantastic
because with everybody having previously
succumbed to the anti-life virus which
is really this story stand in for a
zombie virus if we want to call it what
it is that you have all these people
that are basically snapping back right
they're all basically coming back to
normal but here's the kicker remember
erebos is the one behind all of this
which is to say the anti-life virus
originated with him it was dark side at
the very beginning of the story of
deceased itself basically tapping into
the power of Erebus without really
understanding what it was that he was
doing to put this in more practical
terms what Darkseid did is he took a
drop of ink and he put it in a glass of
water it just changed everything right
that's literally what he did that drop
of ink of course being the power or the
influence of Erebus to basically affect
and destroy this whole really the whole
universe to be honest because everybody
Across the Universe was infected here
but of course with like Supergirl Kara
zorrell coming back this was one of the
crueler moments because remember in the
DC story when she was shot to Earth she
didn't actually go to earth like she
does in the main DC Universe instead she
went to the realm of the new gods and
was immediately attacked and turned into
a zombie and so that's why here when she
initially comes across Superman her
initial response is no there's no way
you're Superman caramel is a baby
because up to this point she never met
him I remember Supergirl comes from Argo
City it was one of the last surviving
cities when Krypton was destroyed but
Superman was a baby by the time Krypton
died so of course given time dilation
and aging differences and so on and so
forth that's why he's basically aged up
here so for her it's coming across
someone from Krypton who survived
outside of herself but not the person
that she recalls now the bigger takeaway
from this and this is one of the bigger
things that goes on here there's two
massive shifts that go on the first is
that Darkseid joins the heroes now one
of the reasons why this happens even
though Darkseid won't readily admit it
is because he needs the heroes right and
in fact darkseid's gonna have this
amazing moment here in a little while
but like he needs the heroes right so
it's kind of like there's no way for him
to defeat erebos on his own but the
other thing that goes on here is the
black racer joins in now remember the
black racer is one of the many aspects
of death that exists in DC Comics and so
having all these Heavy Hitters on their
sides these are some of the most
powerful beings to ever exist in DC
Comics what's so funny is that the
solution for everything comes from
Damien Wayne the Son of Batman now of
course Bruce Wayne for those of you guys
who are just joining us he died at the
very beginning of deceased Bruce Wayne
Dick Grayson Tim Drake they're all dead
right Damian Wayne is the only real
surviving member of the immediate bat
family which is to say basically like
anybody who played the role of Robin
he's the only surviving person but he
ends up meeting with the black racer and
he says my father and my brothers taught
me to respect all life but before I was
Batman before I was Robin I was an
assassin I was raised to look for
weaknesses now what he's talking about
here for all the new folks is remember
during Grant Morrison's Batman run
Damien Wayne was initially introduced as
basically being the Son of Batman that
he never knew about that there through
some pretty shady stuff Talia al Ghul
gave birth to Damien and then Damien
being trained by Talia al Ghul and her
ilk was just dropped up on the doorstep
of Batman and was like now he's yours to
race so Bruce Wayne had to teach Damien
that he can't just kill anybody who
commits a crime it was a great story
it's called Batman and Son it was a
great story Grant Morrison's run on
Batman is phenomenal and we'll probably
cover it right beyond what we've done
already but it was a great story the
bigger thing here though is that when
Damien talks about this he was an
assassin but that's what he says I've
been thinking about how to take the
fight to the source
Erebus is a primordial deity it's the
personification of Darkness the only
thing that can destroy the dark is light
Erebus is anti-life and I have an idea I
want you to tell me if it will work I
want you to confirm this and I can end
this being I'd like your help to do so
and so this is an important distinction
to understand
Erebus is about as close as DC Comics
gets to what is by all standards of
measurement a cosmic into T in Marvel
Comics right a primordial being a being
that's been around since the beginning
of everything in existence and
represents a particular concept but of
course following this Damien goes to
meet with Cyborg and they have this bit
of a conversation right Damien Wayne
kind of spills the beans to cyborg in
terms of what his plan is and then they
call together all the surviving
superheroes and super villains because
remember in this conflict there are no
heroes and villains anymore right
there's not really like the good guys
fighting the bad guys or anything along
those lines it's just the survivors and
the dead and so with this great big huge
conversation that goes on what they
realize is that in order to access
erebos they have to go through what's
called a doom tube the problem with this
is the only way to pass through a doom
tube is to be dead and so in order to
pull that off what they're going to do
is literally die right they're gonna
basically have their hearts shut down
and that in the moment when they've
passed they're gonna move through the
Doom tube and then arrive at aerobos and
to do that they're gonna bring war world
now this is cool right because War World
historically speaking in DC Comics has
just quite literally been exactly what
it sounds like a war-torn world it's ran
by Mongol it's basically a place where
you have like endless gladiatorial
fights just an amazing concept right
it's a really really cool Concept in BC
now of course Darkseid chimes in and
goes as far as to say like dark side
will face Erebus right of course you
know then Guy Gardner chimes in and Guy
Gardner basically gets uh he gets
smacked around a bit for his troubles
the other part of this though is they
reveal that in order to gain the
attention of Erebus they need forces
powerful enough to effectively distract
him and so we're dark sides on board
they even turn to the God of War Aries
now of course Ares ever one of the more
interesting characters in DC Comics and
for reasons that I'll never fully
understand Tom Taylor loves this guy
like every story he does has the God of
War Aries in some capacity he loves this
dude and I don't blame him right under
any normal circumstance Aries is a hoss
like this guy is an absolute he's
literally the God of War like he's just
one of the coolest characters in DC but
despite all the power that he has he
just tells them Point Blank I'm not
going in there to fight Erebus that's a
suicide mission like I'm not going in
there to do that I'm just gonna stand
back and watch and that's when Cassie
Sands Mark chimes in and calls him a
coward but she literally calls Ares the
god of war a coward to his face right
she was like there's a battle to be
fought and your plan is to hide from him
right and where his response is Aries
does not hide the response of Lois right
stepping in Lois Lane right she steps in
she's like really where were you when my
son was standing between this planet and
Annihilation right and even the black
racers chimes in and says if you face
Erebus tomorrow old God you will not be
alone I will be beside you death has
always followed war and so it's really
kind of cornering Aries the God of War
and basically making him fulfill his
role so ultimately he ends up joining in
right it's kind of like okay fine look
I'll do it then right like I'll go ahead
and do this thing that would also
complicates things a little bit is that
during the time when deceased was
happening you actually saw alliances and
even romances forming where they
normally never would have one of the
romances that formed was between Damian
Wayne and Cassie which if I'm being
honest with you guys I kind of hope this
becomes a main DC Universe thing I don't
actually know that's going on right now
I'm not current with the robin series
and Damian Wayne so if you know leave a
comment down below and let me know but I
kind of want to see like Damien Wayne
and Cassie sandsmart get together right
like like wonder what I want to see them
like get together because they just make
a great couple because like they're both
just so headstrong and so independent
and it's just really awesome to see it
play out the problem with this is that
Damien actually tries to convince her to
stay behind and saying that like what
we're gonna have here is we're gonna
have a situation where all these
kryptonians that have previously been
confined to the bottled city of Candor
right have now been freed as a result of
deceased they need to be trained they
need to be taught how to fight all that
kind of stuff they need you to organize
and structure them and teach them battle
formations he's kind of trying to keep
her there he's kind of trying to keep
her away from the main conflict as a
whole not in so many words I mean she
even goes as far as to say if you're
trying to spare me from what's going on
he says fear you you're Wonder Woman I'm
asking The Greatest Warrior I know to
protect the entire universe and her
response is really what's the weapon
Damien this thing you and Cyborg have
come up with and where he won't tell her
she says and conveniently I won't be
with you to see it and that's where he
kind of plays this role and he was like
does I mean do you really believe that I
don't want you beside me I really really
do but but you need to be here to
basically teach people how to fight the
superhero numbers have been drastically
reduced so on and so forth he's trying
to keep her there now he's doing it out
of love and he's doing it out of concern
but again Cassie is one of the most
amazing female characters in DC she's
pissed because she wants to fight she
wants to be there in this battle and be
a part of it she doesn't want to be kept
and so it's one of the coolest things
about her character I love the role that
Cassie sandsmark plays here and Tom
Taylor does a great job of writing her
right then of course you get this really
really cool moment where I could again
this is all kind of leading up to this
big thing you have this cool moment
where Jonathan Kent meets with Damien
only for us to find out that it's
Damian's birthday and so where Jonathan
says if you're really gonna go through
what this plan with like the whole life
force and all that kind of stuff and
you're leading the charge then you need
to represent life right so what he does
is he gives him a new Batman suit that
is totally draped and white and it looks
dope like we'll see what it looks like
when he's wearing it because he looks
amazing in an all-white bat suit oh my
God right now here's a funny thing Tom
Taylor's not pulling this out of nowhere
Jeff Johns did this during his Green
Lantern run there was a point where
Batman became the White Lantern which is
basically like initially started with
Kyle Raynor and Kyle Rayner became space
Jesus but like being a White Lantern is
what happens when you master all the
other lantern rings and then just kind
of Usher yourself in to a higher level
of power now for Damien he hasn't
achieved that level of power it's really
more just a ceremonial Garb if we're
being honest with ourselves right that's
really more what this represents but
he's kind of wearing this outfit as a
representation of the life force itself
so like the good versus the evil light
versus dark that kind of thing and so
once they're all basically kind of tied
into war world and then they in turn
shut down all their hearts and enter
through the Doom tube and into the realm
of Erebus we get what is quite likely
one of the most amazing depictions of a
character in the history of DC Comics I
love the way this guy looks why I just
love the way this guy appears he looks
absolutely awesome and so when you have
Aries and you have the black racer who
appear before Erebus he pays attention
to them right and he says Ares and the
black racer such little things when
there is no one left to fight a war when
there's nothing living to die there will
still be Darkness I gotta say man it's
one of the most intimidating statements
that I think I've seen like a god-like
primordial being make in comics it's
dope and so they have immediately go on
the attack now what's funny about this
is Tom Taylor kind of leans into the
idea that they're basically ants
throwing little sticks at a human being
that it doesn't make any difference at
all right like Oliver Queens got like
The Arrow of Apollo along with a bow
right you have like the the heroes who
are launching an attack against Erebus
but they're literally tearing them open
right like cutting a hole in him but
that's kind of the benefit while Tom
Taylor leans into it and almost makes it
appear a little comedic right in the
sense that it's like what are they
really going to do against this guy
that's the overall point the fact that
he wouldn't pay any attention to them
because he considers them so
insignificant that's their weapon that's
their benefit because cutting him open
and then forcing war world inside that's
when everything changes because what
happens here is that cyborg tapping into
his own memories right like accessing
his own systems to ensure the plan goes
through realizes the life force is no
longer in him again remember the life
force was instilled inside cyborg which
is how they were able to synthesize a
cure for the anti-life virus in the
first place and make everybody normal
again but what Damian Wayne realize is
that at some point in the past that
Bruce Wayne his father he says he was a
paranoid man and you were bonded to
apocalyptian technology right Bruce
didn't just hide a Tracker in cyborg he
hacked Cyborg's entire system years ago
and left control with Damian and so
Damien says I had a theory the anti-life
virus left out of your mind I need the
opposite and I found it in you I found
the life equation I extracted it and I
erased it from all of your system now it
only exists in me this is a sacrifice
it's what Damian Wayne is doing he's
literally taken the life equation from
cyborg imbued it with himself with the
intention of entering into Erebus
through war world and then in turn
detonating and wiping out aerobos but at
the same time basically creating a whole
new universe in the process it's amazing
like it's one of the most crazy things
to happen with Damien and so where
cyborg realizes there's no way to stop
him and Damien basically teleports out
before cyborg can do anything in turn
Cyborg joins the rest of the forces and
when they ask him where's Damien at his
response is Damien isn't coming now
initially Darkseid believes that like
the weapon failed and if it did they've
got minutes to get out of this entire
realm of Erebus before they're either
destroyed by him or converted into dead
beings as a result of just being in his
realm but the response here of cyborg is
no the weapon did not falter the weapon
is Damien he's taken the life equation
into himself he intends to travel there
and then basically destroy Erebus in the
process and so Damien does have a few
kind of momentary goodbyes specifically
talking to Oliver Queen not the most
important thing but it is a bit of a
cool moment here because in turn Aries
the God of War is seemingly destroyed
and then when Damien teleports inside of
Erebus
Erebus starts talking to him right he
refers to him as mortal and then he says
like aerobos I was wondering when I'd
hear from you and Airbus responds this
will destroy you too and the response of
Damian is not really I'll just become
something else and so where araba says
I'm willing to bargain the response of
Damien is for your existence no you took
my father you took my brothers you've
hurt my friends and you took so much
from our world from our universe and
when Erebus asked what do you want from
me the response of Damien is the most
Damian Wayne response ever he says
nothing you pissed me off there will be
no bargain this will just be your end
and it's the most Damian Wayne thing
ever now here's what's so cool about
this right the sacrifice of Damien Wayne
here only really has significance to you
if you're familiar with the history of
his character in DC if you're not really
familiar with the history and the story
of Damien to a degree it's kind of lost
on you but Damien in a lot of ways just
killed he was death incarnate he would
kill indiscriminately in fact one of the
first stories where he appeared he
killed a guy who was a thief he cut his
head off because any and all crimes need
to be paid for with death right a person
and has to die for any crime that they
commit so to be a person raised with
such an extreme view right such a black
and white and binary view of life and
death Crime and Punishment coming to a
person or becoming a person that's
willing to sacrifice their life to save
a universe is a complete and total 180
for his character and so what makes this
really cool is Jonathan Kin steps in
right now this story we can largely kind
of assume the history between Jonathan
and Damian is very much the same even
during their younger years right the
super Sons the teenage superhero team or
at least the young kid superhero team
which by the way if you've never read
super Sons one of the most fun stories
ever in the history of DC Comics it was
amazing it was just it was so fun it was
a blast but what they realize is there's
no way for them to extract Damien alive
it's not going to happen in order for
Erebus to die Damien has to die as well
so Jonathan chooses to stay behind now
his father won't let him right like like
Superman does not want Jonathan to stay
there but the response of Alfred as the
Specter is I will get him out Clark
right I will extract uh Jonathan in time
for him to survive the destruction of
this universe but it's just this amazing
moment where literally Alfred and
Jonathan and Damien are just sitting
together the three of them are just
together and just talking and it's an
incredibly beautiful moment because
Jonathan and Damian are best friends and
that that Damien is the last son that
Alfred really has right like he viewed
Batman as a son he viewed Damien as a
son or potentially a grandson but he was
basically family and so with the death
of Damien Alfred will officially lose
the last remaining member of his family
but they have to let him do it they have
to let him make this sacrifice it's so
beautiful the way it was done because
Damien says if I told you what I was
doing you never would have let me go
through with it and the response to
Jonathan is no I wouldn't I was right
you were a great Batman and the response
of Damien is thank you John and then he
explodes right he detonates and so when
Erebus is basically killed in this
massive explosion Alfred gets Jonathan
out of there they get through a portal
right they get back to the real world
itself and then in turn Alfred has this
kind of inner monologue where he says I
visit sometimes the cosmos Damien made I
Glide past its new Sons and I walk over
its cooling planets I had no idea how
much apparent would sacrifice for a
child not until I had my own did I
understand what I would give up for them
what I would do if any harm came to them
how deeply I could miss them my bats my
sons my whole universe it is this just
beautiful ending to what is one of the
darkest stories that DC did but I loved
it oh my God so this is the end of of
deceased guys this is the conclusion of
the story and I think it's probably one
of the greatest stories DC's done I
wouldn't even say the last five years
I'd say last 10 years let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace